bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
l'audition d'alain rousset le président
socialiste de l'association des régions
de france qui a été auditionné hier
après midi au sénat par la commission
des lois dans le cadre des travaux
préparatoires à la réforme territoriale
réforme qui est d'ailleurs passé en
conseil des ministres hier midi à
l'arrière à la rouste et n'est pas venu
seul puisqu'il est venu accompagné de
nombreux autres présidents de région qui
sont venus dire leur avis sur la
nouvelle carte des régions qui a été
dévoilée par françois hollande au début
juin de france à 14 super région qui va
faire l'objet de la réforme territoriale
de la première partie de la réforme
territoriale qui sera examiné par le
sénat à partir du 1er juillet je vous
rappelle que la réforme territoriale est
d'abord examiné par le sénat c'est une
exigence constitutionnelle puisqu'elle
concerne les territoires et que le sénat
représente constitutionnellement ces
mêmes territoires tout de suite donc
retour à cette audition d'alain rousset
c'était hier après midi au sénat
bien mesdames et messieurs
pardon des mois pour se
léger retard je ne vais pas me
substituer au président de la commission
des lois mais s'il le permet simplement
dire deux mots pour ce moment que nous
avons souhaité organiser
sous la présidence du président de la
commission des lois et en présence du
président du sénat mon introduction
monsieur le président sera très brève
j'aurais fabre je n'ai pas besoin qu'il
me donne la parole puisque je souhaite
m'exprimer très brièvement dans un
premier temps pour simplement préciser
le cadre de cette discussion et c'est
très simple de le faire puisque vous
êtes tous très au courant je veux
remercier nos collègues présidents des
régions
remercié le président de la rfa les
roues c'est en leur donnant tous ceux
qui nous ont rejoints qui ont répondu à
cette invitation
vous le savez c'est une commission
élargie le gouvernement a déposé ce
matin a présenté par d'un conseil des
ministres
deux textes dont un qui sera examiné
rapidement le 1er juillet et nous avons
souhaité avec le président de la
commission des lois pouvoir très vite je
crois que c'est le cas
organiser un échange avec les présidents
de région sur ce premier texte pour
recueillir leurs leur leur avis a même
temps organiser peut-être un échange
avec mes collègues sénatrice sénateurs
qui sont qui sont ici présents vous
souvenez des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale certains d'entre
vous les évoque lors de certains débats
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
l'esprit des états généraux puisse
planer au dessus de notre de noé charge
mais un temps comprenez qu'il n'était
pas possible d'organiser
des états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale dans un délai aussi court
compte tenu de ce que furent les états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
qui ont tout de même permis de
rassembler plusieurs centaines d'élus
dans les départements
presque plusieurs milliers et puis
ensuite ici au sénat et ensuite à la
sorbonne donc nous voulons que chacun
puisse ici s'exprimer bien sûr penser
qualités respectives mais aussi les
présidents de région qui souhaiterait
pouvoir
communiquer aux sénatrices et sénateurs
leur point de vue et leur avis sur la
réforme qui est en cours voilà monsieur
le président moi j'ai voulu qu'en
puissent avoir cet échange qui nous
avait été demandé par certains de nos
collègues qu'on puisse le faire dans un
cadre un peu particulier c'est pourquoi
je me suis permis de prendre la parole
avant vous mais je vous la restitue tout
de suite pour que vous puissiez mener le
débat comme il se doit merci monsieur le
président cher jean pierre bel au
contraire je dois dire au nom des
collègues que nous sommes très honorés
et sensible au fait que le président du
sénat est bien voulu venir participer à
cette rencontre
en effet le comm e jean pierre bel l'a
rappelé il fut à l'initiative de ces
états généraux des collectivités locales
qui ont beaucoup marqué qui ont permis
un travail très approfondi sur la
première loi qui a été adopté je dois
dire que cette première loi qui a été
adoptée qui a créé notamment les
métropoles a donné lieu à un travail
très approfondi du sénat et si on
regarde la majorité qui a voté cette loi
puisqu'il ya une majorité au sénat je
puis dire qu'elle a été assez plurielle
et que des efforts sont venus de divers
horizons
pour faire exister par exemple les
métropoles bien ce qui prouve que le
sénat monsieur le président a des
capacités particulières pour opérer un
certain nombre de convergences en ce qui
concerne les collectivités locales
aujourd'hui la commission des lois a
choisi d'organiser une réunion publique
ouverte à tous les sénateurs et je
remercie au nom de mes collègues de la
commission des lois tous les sénateurs
qui se venus nombreux
signe que ce sujet nous passionne
nous allons eux passer deux heures si
vous le voulez bien jusqu'à 16 heures 15
dans cette réunion après quoi nous
recevrons monsieur bernard cazeneuve
ministre de l'intérieur
n'ont pas deux heures oui je suis un peu
inflationniste mais seulement pour les
minutes pas pour d'autres sujets et je
vais vous donner la parole et je veux
saluer tout particulièrement les
présidents de région qui sont venus très
nombreux
choix dire que l'un des premiers mérite
des initiatives du gouvernement il ya
peut-être certaines critiques qui
existent sans nul doute mais c'est que
jamais nous n'avons reçu en même temps
au temps du président de région c'est un
honneur pour le sénat monsieur le
président du sénat et donc je veux veux
les remercier très sincèrement
et je souhaite vraiment la bienvenue à
alain rousset monsieur le président de
la rs président par ailleurs de la
région aquitaine à jean paul huchon
président de la région
ile-de-france à rené souchon président
de la région auvergne
à laurent beauvais président président
de la région basse normandie mais qui
n'est pas du tout bas ce qui est dans
notre coeur
à marie-guite dufay présidente de la
région franche comté à philippe richert
président de la région alsace à jacques
auxiette président de la région pays de
loire à françois patriat que nous voyons
plus souvent lui mais il ya des raisons
de bonnes raisons d'ailleurs président
de la région bourgogne
à jean marie beffara vice président de
la région centre et à gérard
vandenbroeck près vice président de la
région limousin
je salue aussi notre rapporteur me
michel delebarre rapporteur pour la
commission des lois de ce texte je vais
vous proposer messieurs mais madame et
messieurs les présidents
d'abord de nous faire quelques propos
introductif je ne sais pas comment vous
allez vous vous organiser
nous savons bien qu'il ya quelques
débats sur des histoires vous savez de
sais pas comment on dit découpage c'est
ça le périmètre trimestre mais il ya
d'autres débats et nous sommes nombreux
à penser que la france gagnera avoir des
régions fortes encore plus forte et que
cela est une question de compétence une
question de finances et de moyens et je
pense qu'avant de parler des question de
périmètre entre parlerons certainement
nous serons nous serions très heureux de
vous entendre sur finalement le projet
des présidents de région et des régions
de france par rapport au devenir à
l'avenir à la force et vitalité de nos
régions pour l'économie pour l'emploi
pour le développement de notre pays pour
j'arrête là je donne en premier la
parole à monsieur président rousset si
jean pierre tu es d'accord et puis après
vous allez chacun vous exprimer de telle
manière qu'on puisse donner la parole à
pro collègues pour vous interroger et
que vos billets répondre ensuite
monsieur le président
bien
messieurs les présidents
cher jean pierre
voilà merci en tout cas de nous de nous
recevoir dans cette enceinte et et danse
devant
les sénateurs qui s'intéresse lui partie
des sénatrices qui intéresse plus
particulièrement à la réforme
territoriale
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui en face
d'une série de textes d'une démarche une
trajectoire qui d'une certaine manière
correspond aux jeux de l'association des
régions de france depuis de longues
années
qu'un texte met en avant les régions
alors que
les comparaisons européennes
l'état des lieux européen
l'efficacité de de l'action publique
notamment dans le coeur du métier des
régions recevoir le développement
économique et l'emploi
ont montré leur efficacité j'y
reviendrai d'un mot tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs
je vous ai amené un certain nombre de
notes de d'analysé et de benchmark de
comparaison à l'échelle européenne que
la rfa fait pour voir quelles
quel est l'état
de comparaison donc qu'un texte arrive
renforçant les régions
et pour nous par delà les sensibilités
politiques
une bonne nouvelle
l'histoire de france c'est fait d'une
certaine manière depuis la révolution
même avant
contre les régions d'une certaine
manière à l'époque c'était les provinces
il se trouve aujourd'hui le modèle
régional n'est pas le seul à être actif
mais en tout cas qu'un modèle de
décentralisation à la française apparaît
qui est un modèle qui
spécialise les compétences et nous
sommes au niveau des régions pour la
spécialisation des compétences
dans un monde plus complexe
international
mondialisée ce n'est pas pareil de
s'occuper
des transports urbains de s'occuper
de l'allongement de la durée de la vie
de s'occuper de la solidarité même si
les choses peuvent avoir des
interférences et de s'occuper du
développement des entreprises
de notre
de notre pays
je voudrais juste commencer par vous
donner un chiffre
qui est important les régions françaises
investissent en innovation auprès de
leurs pme sur leurs pme 400 millions
d'euros par an
ce plan du développement économique en
général c'est un peu plus de 2 milliards
ce que font les départements aussi dans
une complémentarité
400 millions d'euros pour les régions
françaises 9 milliards d'euros 9
milliards d'euros + d'ailleurs pour les
landes normalement
nous nous trouvons donc dans une
situation où même si j'ajoute
les aides de l'état
le sait hier ne correspond pas une aide
à l'innovation c'est plutôt une aide à
la recherche
les aides de la bpi sont plutôt des
prêts il reste le f lui et il reste les
aides aux pôles de compétitivité qui
font en gros 400 millions d'euros
si
nous développons cette idée que le coeur
de nos compétences est essentielle à la
france et à son redressement productif
c'est pour des raisons de comparaison
tout bête d'eau pme françaises sont en
compétition comme nos deux pays avec
les outils et les entreprises allemand a
mis en compétition je rappelle que nous
avons en france mais ce sont les
entreprises qui créent le plus de
richesses et d'emplois mis le pays est
indépendant pour 15000 en allemagne
si j'arrive à la comparaison maintenant
de la dépense publique
global des régions françaises par
rapport aux régions européennes qu'elle
soit italienne du nord autrichiennes
allemandes régions françaises dépensent
395 euros par habitant
la moyenne européenne est entre 3000 et
5000 euros
alors bien entendu les compétences sont
complètement différentes il ya toute une
partie d'action sociale
de ces mêmes de sécurité sociale mais si
je suis à iso compétences
les mêmes compétences
nous sommes de 1 à 5
de 1 à 5
ce qui fait que je je reprends
volontiers
la comparaison où
l'idée qui évoquait jean pierre sueur
tout à l'heure le problème pour nous et
- la taille que la puissance
que les compétences
si je prends maintenant le problème par
le biais de l'intérêt de nos concitoyens
et de ce que nous souhaitons je crois
tout ce savoir qui fait quoi dans ce
pays
martin malvy et alain lambert ont
présidé une commission d' analyse
extrêmement intéressante et et martin
malvy hier dans une réunion des
présidents de conseils régionaux
nous citer cet exemple que
les financements croisés sur un même
dossier parfois
7,4 entre 4 à cet interlocuteur coûte à
chaque fois en termes d'ingénierie
publique 800 euros
800 euros
nous nous trouvons donc dans un système
de dilution des responsabilités
d'exacerbation du coût de l'action
publique
alors où en même temps l'état pour ses
politiques régaliennes se trouve en
peine sur la sécurité sur la santé sur
la justice sur l'armée d'avoir à faire
face
à la nécessité de faire évoluer ses
politiques la décentralisation est donc
pour peu qu'elle soit claire
responsabilisante un acte de réformes
d'économie de l'action publique
d'efficacité de l'action publique
ce n'est pas à l'égard des collègues
sénateurs que je vais rappeler que
chaque fois qu'une compétence a été
transférée
à une collectivité locale
exclusivement elle a été parfaitement
gérée que ce soit les lycées ou les
collèges où que ce soit les ter je
rappelle que les ter il ya 12 ans était
moribond ils ont été ressuscités
bien entendu le modèle économique et
fiscale qui était le nôtre jusqu'à la
fin des années 2000
nous a permis cela
les régions sur les lycées par exemple
dépenses
en euros constants six fois plus qu'elle
ne dépense que nos dépenses l état à
l'époque mais aujourd'hui on peut être
assez fier du résultat puisque grâce aux
régions la france est classée sur le
plan de l'équipement numérique et
informatique des lycées au troisième
rang des pays européens
les collèges on est septième
mais c'est pas grave on est en tête on
est dans le top ten
je m'exprime au nom des régions je
m'exprime pas aux non moins chers
collègues je n'ai pas à ben
je suis invité pour ça donc
nous trouvons dans un modèle aujourd'hui
dans l'efficience par rapport au coût
doit être réhabilité je vous donne un
autre exemple
qui est celui du service public de
l'emploi
le service public de l'emploi
aujourd'hui est émiettée dans une région
comme la bretagne midi-pyrénées ou
l'aquitaine c'est plus de 170 organismes
qui concourent à la réinsertion des
chômeurs
sur
et est encore une fois à périmètre
constant en allemagne
à périmètre et à coût moindre en
allemagne le service public de l'emploi
mais
150 conseillers devant dix mille
chômeurs
130 en angleterre
71 en france
et nous avons quatre cents 400 mille
emplois non pourvus
donc vous comprenez que sur la base de
ces
de ces analyses
nous pensons qu'une réforme et que des
progrès sont possibles
l'émission de la région et les régions
françaises ne souhaite pas élargir leur
champ de compétence autre que leur coeur
de métier
pourvu que ce métier-là de faire du
développement économique d'accompagner
les entreprises
soient exercées complètement
et le problème se pose d'ailleurs moins
par rapport aux autres collectivités
qu'ils ne se posent par rapport à l'état
le vrai enjeu de cet acte de
décentralisation
que nous appelons de nos voeux et que le
président a je crois président de la
république et je crois bien écrit dans
la presse quotidienne régionale
c'est bien qu'on sache ce que fait
l'état ce que font les régions où ce que
font les autres collectivités
sur l'innovation par exemple
nous avons des interventions de l'état
sur des compétitions d'entreprise la
meilleure pme technologique
sur le le fonds unique interministériel
pour les pôles de compétitivité sur des
aides qui transitent par la bpi
sur des aides de la direccte
on a sur l'accompagnement sur oscille à
la déconcentration à l'intérieur de la
déconcentration puisque une structure
comme l'ademe par exemple non seulement
à une tête capable de de concevoir des
transitions mais en même temps
chargé de mission sur le terrain nous
disons nous simplement que la france ne
peut plus se payer aujourd'hui la
déconcentration et la décentralisation
qu'il faut choisir
surtout que le mélange des deux
induit un nomadisme de la part des
chômeurs d'un côté les chefs
d'entreprise de l'autre
qui coûte cher et qui est préjudiciable
à l'efficacité à la rapidité de la
décision publique le temps de la
décision publique et le coup de la
décision publique sont plus chers et
plus longs en france que dans les autres
pays européens et singulièrement ceux
qui réussissent
premier point que je voulais évoquer
devant vous en vous re dix ans et nous
avons amené un certain nombre de
dossiers de comparaison que
je vous remets très peut-être que le
président de la commission puisqu'il n'y
en a pas assez pour à pour à dupliquer
le texte les textes qui nous sont
soumises je ne
préjuge pas de ce que l'on dira les uns
et les autres ici sur le découpage des
régions
après tout
il ya eu plusieurs cartes la carte
mauroy la carte balladur jean pierre
raffin et
et le collègue krattinger ont aussi
travaillé sur ces cartes et
quand on travaille avec des géographes
la solution optimale serait plutôt de de
passer entre les départements
ou d'avoir un découpage infrarégionales
plutôt que une fusion des régions
président de la république a souhaité
pour des raisons de simplicité de garder
la dimension régionale et d'ailleurs
vous le verrez dans une carte que nous
vous soumettons cette carte régionale
qui date de 1956 à créer des flux
objectif domicile travail santé
transports etc etc éducation qui sont à
l'intérieur des régions d'aujourd'hui à
deux exceptions près en france à deux
exceptions près
un mot sur
sur le souci les régions d'aujourd'hui
les régions d'aujourd'hui sont devenus
la collectivité qui est la plus
dépendantes des dotations de l'état
où le modèle notamment des ter et de la
sncf est un modèle qu'on ne peut plus
accompagner
nous avons accompagné la résurrection si
j'ose dire du ter aujourd'hui les
régions ne peuvent plus le faire un tel
point que beaucoup d'entre nous ont cap
et les conventions avec la sncf
pour des raisons de pas citer
pour des raisons inflationnistes et puis
parce que nous sommes soumis des double
peine jeu nous en discutions ce matin et
jacques auxiette pourra préciser les
choses mais on doit par exemple
subventionner les gares
et en même temps payer les droits
d'usagé
donc on se trouve dans un système qui
n'est plus qui n'est plus acceptable
pour nous
à destination des métropoles
les régions demain avec la disparition
des conseils généraux auront une tâche
importante avec les intercommunalités
hors métropole
sur les territoires fragiles
d'abord parce que nous devons faire face
à une histoire française
continûment assumée par des
gouvernements de sensibilités
différentes qui fait qu'on a plus
accompagner les territoires riches en
termes de dotation de bonus ce terme a
été utilisé que les territoires plus
fragiles
ce qui pose un problème
en matière de de péréquation et de
financement d'un certain nombre de
territoires ruraux notamment
ou autour des petites vies nous plaidons
pour un renforcement de
l'intercommunalité nous plaidons même
pour la reconstruction le la
revivification de la notion de pays de
retrouver au niveau des pays un
rassemblement de l'intercommunalité avec
un vrai pouvoir exécutif l'émiettement
est insupportable et trop coûteux
c'est dans ce domaine la
chaux les métropoles
nous souhaitons qu'on soit très
attentifs
justement parce que 60 % de l'industrie
française sont hors territoire
métropolitain
nous disons qu'il faut être prudent sur
une exception métropolitaine en matière
de compétence économique
sinon là où est la richesse
là sera l'emploi demain avec une
capacité qui fait que l'aide aux
entreprises sera beaucoup plus élevée en
territoire métropolitain qu'en
territoire rural ou en territoire de
petites de petite ou de moyenne veut
faut être attentif à ça si on veut pas
avoir un territoire qui se dépeuple et
qui aggrave la désertification
et et un déséquilibre
qui serait pénalisant d'ailleurs pour
les entreprises parce que beaucoup
d'entreprises je pense notamment à la
vendée ou à d'autres territoires se sont
développées dans des zones où je pense
aux territoires de la kossi dans les
pyrénées atlantiques où il ya pu y avoir
un équilibre
urbain rural ou plutôt industriel rural
sur sur un certain nombre sur un certain
nombre d'emplois pour revenir au
département
aujourd'hui ce qui nous inquiète dans le
texte
dans les textes c'est
comment
oui mais je les deux choses sont un peu
lié c'est super mais bon voilà
sur le problème des compétences à
l'égard des départements voit bien qu'on
va transférer aux régions les collèges
les routes et les transports
interurbains
transports scolaires si les régions ne
récupère pas ne reprennent pas la
compétence ça les actions économiques
des départements en d'autres termes si
bercy fait disparaître
les deux milliards d'euros commettent
les départements
c'est autant que nos pme n'auront pas
sur le territoire c'est une aggravation
du handicap français à l'égard de l'aide
à l'innovation et à l'entreprise et il
en est de même pour le tourisme pour
l'été hisser pour la
transition énergétique donc nous sommes
très attentifs et nous aussi
à cela
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire les
régions sont bien sûr sensible à leurs
compétences coeur métier formation
emploi développement industriel
recherche elles sont aussi sensibles à
l' équilibre des territoires et à
l'action contractuels que nous pouvons
mener sur
l'ensemble de ces territoires qui
n'auraient pas la puissance fiscale que
les métropoles peuvent avoir
un je remercie le président alain
rousset pour cet exposé qui nous a déjà
beaucoup donné d'éléments
je précise que le sénat ait saisi du
premier texte deux textes ont été
adoptés aux pensées des ministres ce
matin nous sommes saisis du premier ne
seront saisis ultérieurement du second
mais bien sûr il est difficile de
plaider que cela ne fait pas un ensemble
alors je vais vous proposer mes chers
collègues de donner la parole à chacun
des présidents de région en leur
demandant
s'ils veulent bien chacun à mettre
l'accent sur un ou deux éléments pour
que l'on puisse donner la parole aussi
aux sénateurs en complément de ce qu'a
dit alain rousset qu'on pourrait
considérer comme déjà dit
donc on pourrait commencer par monsieur
le président de la région ile de france
puisqu'il est juste à droite
la droite
c'est réversible avoir eu peur oui
voilà alors merci monsieur huchon mais
ces paysans
mais ce président de la commission
michel barré les rapporteurs jeu
j'essaie d'être court pour ne pas redire
ce qu'a dit alain rousset avec eux
lequel je suis tout à fait d'accord sur
le fond la question n'est pas une
affaire de taille c'est une affaire de
compétence de puissance et donc parce
qu'on n'insiste jamais assez là dessus
de moyens
avec une recette dynamique parce
qu'aujourd'hui très franchement moi je
dispose dans ma région qui est quand
même lourd daf porté à gérer de 8 euros
sur 100 de dépenses qui me sont
imputables
à ma politique financière tout le reste
c'est l'état or l'état se retirent
massivement il ya cette économie
budgétaire mortelle de 10 à 11 milliards
sur les collectivités locales
moi je commence la discussion sur le
budget
2015 comme anne hidalgo avec le même
chiffre moins 400 millions
au début de la discussion militaire
c'est-à-dire dix poissons de mon budget
que je ne retrouverai pas donc il faut
bien voir que notre situation est très
particulier à celles des régions sauf
que je dirais fait que en termes de
puissance cadiale 1 est très juste un
exemple
le pays basque espagnol qui n'est pas
une région aussi importante
ni pour l'économie du pays ni pour ses
habitants que la région ile de france le
budget du pays basque et de huit fois
supérieur au nôtre et nous sommes la
plus grosse région française avec
presque 5 milliards de budget dont vous
voyez
qu'en terme de deux puissances on est
très très loin de nos concurrents
internationaux
j'ai juste revenir aussi sur la question
des compétences à lundi notre coeur de
métier ces formations
développement économique innovation
c'est vrai mais en région ile de france
il oblige je ne gère que ce n'est pas
tout à fait exact notre coeur de métier
chez les transports la moitié de mon
budget 2 milliards pratiquement est
consacrée au transport tous les ans en
plus nous avons à gérer un projet
absolument monstrueux intéressant mais
monstrueux quel grand paris et que de ce
fait on oublie toujours que quand on
parle du grand paris où tout le monde
dit mais c'est pas grave c'est la
société du grand paris c'est d'état etc
mais attention hein c'est pas du tout
vrai parce que c'est de l'argent est
prélevée sur la richesse des entreprises
et 2 surtout en 2020 quand le truc va
commencer à circuler
c'est l'agent ile de france qui va se
voir payer l'exploitation et le
fonctionnement je ne vous raconte pas ce
serait compliqué et très difficile et
nous avons fait vraiment en matière de
transport une véritable révolution avec
toutes les régions mais en ville de
france encore plus qu'ailleurs puisque
il ya soixante dix pour cent
soixante-dix pour cent des voyageurs
français qui circulent en ile-de-france
qu'on a trop longtemps oublié et que la
sncf commence
à modifier mais avec quelle difficulté
et avec quel taux
dysfonctionnements comme ceux que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
nous le je vais parler que du premier
projet de loi celui dont que vous êtes
en train d'examiner en termes de taille
des régions moi je n'ai rien à dire
chez certains de mes collègues qui m'ont
appelé pour me dire est ce qu'on
pourrait pas franchement non nous sommes
deux millions deux millions et demi
d'habitants
nous représentons 31 % du produit
national brut c'est pas la peine ou
alors fi non il faut nous donner le
grand bassin parisien ceara moitié de la
population française et ça serait assez
ridicule ça n'aurait pas de sens si on
veut que vivent vraiment un esprit
régional un esprit pensable parce qu'il
ya quelque chose qui existe dans les
régions c'est fait ce patriotisme
régional qui finalement n'est dû qu'aux
efforts
des élus heures c'est pas toujours
facile pour toutes les régions mais en
vérité il ya maintenant une vraie
identification comme ailleurs il ya une
certaine identification au département
et c'est une des questions que neuf que
vous avez à traiter que nous avons à
traiter donc sur cette question de
l'élargissement
moi je vais pas me prononcer sur les
agissements pour me fâcher avec personne
évidemment
dans mes collègues mais ce n'est pas la
question centrale pour nous en ile de
france et là je voudrais que vous y
réfléchir en termes presque sur eure de
dire à l'exception francilienne mais il
faut tenir compte de la situation
particulière
nous avons nous un problème avec les
départements et avec la métropole
quand même avec les départements j'ai
fait une proposition elle est
relativement à prouver chez moi je n'ai
pas les os x ministre et par les
autres à porter
nous pensons nous qu'on peut intégrer
les départements dans la région c'est à
dire qu'il ya une assemblée régionale
unique reposant sur des listes élu avec
bien entendu la présence de gens qui
représentent les départements et à la
terre pour gérer les questions qui
restent départementale une commission
permanente spécifiques ça ne demande pas
une décision particulière ça ne donne
pas de révision constitutionnelle ça ne
demande rien c'est une simplification de
la carte est faite aussi une manière de
permettre au département de continuer à
vivre ce match dès le départ quand tout
le monde dit il faut cibler les
partenaires moi j'ai dit c'est pas si
simple
les départements représentent
aujourd'hui une proximité et la région
elle c'est la stratégie
c'est les grands équipements bas il faut
que la région si on décide de supprimer
un échelon devienne quelque chose qui
représente à la fois la stratégie les
grands équipements et la proximité et
c'est le sens de la proposition que j'ai
fait et comme dit manuel valls la
proposition de jean paul est
intéressante mais elle n'est peut-être
pas majoritaires à vous de voir et à
vous de travailler et nous aussi à nous
de travailler pour essayer de faire
avancer ce à d'autant plus qu'un
honnêtement il ya des questions
politiques il ya des questions
politiques voient dans mon assemblée
dans ma région chez huit départements
cinq de gauche 3 de droit
il faut que tout le monde vive et est
par conséquent
moi je ne demande pas je ne demande pas
la disparition de telle ou telle
sensibilité plutôt que je pense que
certains ont raison de s'en inquiéter
donc il faut trouver une représentation
acceptable équitable des intérêts
départementaux quant aux nouvelles
compétences qu'on nous donnerait nos
pense supprimant les départements mais
si j'ai bien compris en les dévitalise
ans de certaines de ses compétences je
reprends le modu secrétaires d'état des
m'a paru un peu une maman un peu mal un
peu maladroit un mot malheureux oui mais
si on doit effectivement
dérivés certaines compétences alors les
collèges c'est complètement normal on
est dans la lignée de ce qu'a lundi sur
l'éducation et c'est vrai quand même que
ont fait un effort monstrueux là-dessus
et il faudra le leulier il ya bien
entendu les routes parce que les
déplacements la mobilité le ferroviaire
les routes où ça peut rentrer dans le
même panier
il reste le social une voix un vrai
sujet très difficile moi je ne pense pas
que la région soit l'échelon pertinent
pour gérer la question sociale le coin
justement il faut inventer cette forme
hérité des départements hérité des
intercommunalités et je dis juste une
dernière chose c'est que je suis très
préoccupé par la question de la
compétence générale et de sa suppression
nous avons nouveautés à l'intérieur de
la rfa après de très longs débats assez
pénible dans lesquels moi j'étais de
ceux qui voulaient confirmer la
compétence générale et tu n'étais pas
tout seul mais on s'est rallié à cette
idée pour des raisons à la fois de
simplification d'économie et tout ce
qu'on voudra et surtout pour être
capable de faire le coeur de métier est
évidemment parce que c'est ça qui est
important mais je vous dis il faut faire
très attention à la question sociale moi
je ne vois pas j'ai déjà dit dans un
article un long chemin du matin je ne
vois pas comment un préfet pourra me
dire en vertu de la disparition de la
compétence générale
je vous interdit de venir en aide à une
association d'autistes de handicapés ou
de personnes touchées par lg mère
faudrait qu'on m'explique ça faudrait
qu'on me dise je vais voir une tutelle
et il ya aussi une tentation de l'état
de remettre sa tutelle sur les régions
particulier ça c'est quelque chose que
nous je pense nous battrons pour obtenir
de votre côté et je m'arrête là
si jean paul huchon président de la
région ile de france je donne tout de
suite la parole à rené souchon président
de la région auvergne
messieurs les présidents messieurs les
sénateurs merci brièvement puisqu'il est
acquis qu'on ne revient pas sur ce qui a
déjà été dit je me sens très sûr un des
points du projet de loi que vous avez à
examiner et qui concerne la
représentation du président de la région
auvergne petite région mis en 350 mille
habitants qu'on va marier avec une très
grande qui fait 6 million trois cent
mille habitants
immédiatement j'ai été attirée sur un
des points de la nex du projet de loi
qui est le plafonnement à 150 élus de
quatre régions nouvelles dont rhône
alpes auvergne et quand j'ai regardé
très près et le texte encore été
modifiées d'entre eux hier et ce matin
je me suis rendu compte que cette ce
plafonnement écrasé c'est vrai pour les
quatre régions veut chacun pourra dire
dans les selles qui sont concernés
comment il perçoit les choses le texte
tel qu'il est la représentation tel quel
et écrase la plus petite région et l
l'écrasent d'autant plus qu' elle a peu
de population puisque la représentation
est entièrement basé sur la population
et pas du tout sur une représentation
territoriale dont on verra à travers les
faits je vous en ferai pas le détail
mais à travers les compétences régions
des régions on voit bien qu'il ya quand
même un certain nombre de problèmes
lourds et quand on comprend maintenant
les résultats des élections j'ai pris
par exemple les élections
présidentielles bon et j'ai fait une
projection est bien dans la région
auvergne on va se retrouver sur ces
bases là qui seront forcément différente
à 26 élus régionaux
contre 47 aujourd'hui et dans le plus
petit département le cantal un sénateur
méharée là le sénateur jean lié aux 600
du cantal on en aura un ou deux et la
loi prévoit qu'un a au minimum
bon et alors non mais attendez
si maintenant on regarde ça avec les
compétences
la loi nous fait obligation par exemple
d'avoir deux représentants dans les
conseils d'administration des lycées
s'est déjà impossible ça le sera encore
plus tout ça pour dire que les régions
sans des lieux de où on pense on
réfléchit bonne élabore la stratégie de
moyen long terme mais l'ambiguïté c'est
que ce sont aussi des lieux de gestion
de la proximité tout ce qui est
formation de façon globale formation
initiale y compris les cfa formation
continue orientation puisque maintenant
nous ne mente sa carte de déformation
tout cela ne peut pas se gérer
uniquement par une présence de
l'administration autrement dit par une
telle concentration de la région ne
saurait territoire c'est là elle se fera
mais si localement on ne voit jamais
aucun élu j'imagine déjà un conseil
d'administration de lycée où on en prend
déjà plein la figure voilà où le savez
si on voit jamais un conseiller régional
d'aller voir ce que ça va donner ici en
plus demain on a les collèges bon je
m'arrête là c'est un je le dis à
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs siat heures salle cette
représentation ce plafonnement
c'est un très mauvais signe p vis-à-vis
de l'espace à faible densité de
population
et comme j'ai dit que le texte avait été
modifié entre hier et aujourd'hui la
métropole de lyon dans le cas je viens
d'évoquer à en terre en candidat
28-28 nous non candidat sur la liste
l'a34 mais en résultats en résultat
compte tenu du poids de la population et
bien il y aura plus de pensée régionaux
vraisemblablement de la métropole
lyonnaise que de toute l'ancienne région
au vert donc ceci n'est pas possible
voilà ce que je voulais évoquer devant
vous c'est très concret c'est l'article
6 du projet de loi
merci monsieur rené souchon président de
la région auvergne monsieur laurent
beauvais président de la région basse
normandie merci à mon tour
de vous saluer d'être heureux de
participer quelques instants à ces
échanges qui vous paraissent
intéressants à suivre et nourrit on voit
les les camps qui se font non pas
politique mais territoriaux et
va être intéressant de suivre cela il
sera toujours nécessaire d'expliquer que
le périmètre n'a pas de sens sans
réflexion sur les compétences en à
rousset a longuement développé ce point
je veux pas l'enfer plus mais c'est
essentiel évidemment et j'insiste de ce
point de vue là tout particulièrement
sur la question de la compétence
économique
qui doit être très très largement
précise et bien organisée mieux que
apparemment les choses sont fixés
aujourd'hui il ya un point aussi pour ne
pas répéter ce que mon collègue et ami
rené souchon a indiqué sur la
représentation des territoires ruraux il
ya un point particulier je veux mettre
en avant dans ce premier texte puisque
c'est du premier texte on parle c'est
cette question qui apparaît d'ailleurs
sur un terme qui me surprend un peu
compte tenu de la modernité de notre
projet de chef lieu on parle de chef
lieu
bon peut-être qu'on pourrait suggérer
que le terme soit un peu revu et que
cette notion qu'on appelle ailleurs de
capital soit un peu développés précisé
en regard un des problématiques
d'aménagement du territoire que les
régions vont devoir assumer il ya plus
de politique nationale d'aménagement du
territoire il n'y a plus de politique
nationale d'aménagement de territoire on
en est tous conscient donc les régions
on est les nouvelles régions avec ces
périmètres
nouveaux auront à prendre en charge pour
ce qui les concerne des problématiques
d'aménagement du territoire ça renvoie
là aussi aux compétences mais en même
temps la carte et l'organisation des
futures région doit intégrer cela au
delà du mode de représentation de
scrutin je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
aussi aux fonctions capitales entre
guillemets d'un point de vue
d'aménagement du territoire et ceci et
je crois d'autant plus
renforcée quand nous rapprocherons la
notion donc que je crois vraiment à
changer de chef lieu à celles de
métropole puisque les métropoles sont
désormais dotés de compétences et de
pouvoirs importants et la notion
d'aménagement du territoire au sein d'un
périmètre régional de draps être mise en
avant au regard de ses fonctions
capitales entre guillemets des nouvelles
régions jeu je veux insister là dessus
le texte pour l'instant est assez
restreinte dans sa conception mais un la
notion de chef lieu mériterait d'être
modernisé un peu on a eu l'idée des
placements en une journée qui était
celle des chefs de département du xviiie
siècle peut-être qu'on pourrait innover
en trouvant un terme adapter au xxième
dans lequel nous sommes et deuxièmement
de permettre que dans les dispositions
qui seront prises il ya des calendriers
il ya des procédures de consultation et
qu'on passe un peu de temps à définir ce
que les fonctions de direction des
nouvelles régions comme elles devront
être localisée et organisées notamment
au regard de la puissance qu auront
demain les métropoles et que la loi a
déjà défini voilà je voulais insister
sur cette question je précise mais c'est
totalement gratuit que le normand je
suis tout à fait satisfait des
propositions qui sont faites en termes
de
organisation territoriale évidemment
merci à laurent beauvais président de la
région basse normandie
madame marie guide ce buffet du fait
présidente la région franche comté
hochement des régions c'est
à remettre dans l'ensemble d'une vaste
réforme un qui peut aller jusqu'à la
disparition du département qui va en
tout cas englober le renforcement des
intercommunalités dans l'ensemble de
cette réforme territoriale qui pour moi
représente une vraie modernité et à le
vrai moyen d'alléger notre
administration territoriale tout en la
rendant plus efficace tout en la mettant
sur le chemin d'une dynamique économique
je suis vraiment s à 100 % favorables
j'ai eu l'occasion côtés de françois
patriat de le dire très vite je pense
que la france bouge de cette façon et va
dans le bon sens mais c'est parce que
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire de façon
très forte en maths iran a d'ailleurs
des retours dans ma région à des débats
les uns sont pour les autres sont
contraints bon le débat il est comme
partout mais la détermination que j'ai
autour de cette réforme me fait dire
avec force aussi qu'il faut faire
attention et trouver véritablement les
conditions de la réussite et sur le
texte le simple texte que vous avez là
il y à mon avis deux choses à bien
regarder je vais très rapide parce
qu'elles viennent d'être dit mais je
vais le dire d'une autre façon sur la
représentation de la population
je pense qu'il n'est pas bon d'aller
vers une simple agrégation mécanique des
conseillers en fonction de la population
je prends notre exemple bourgogne
franche comté 42 d'un côté 50 de l'autre
on additionne tout ça je pense qu'il
faut trouver une pondération pour
approché c'est pas tout à fait le même
sujet que auvergne englobé dans dans
rhône alpes mais il ya un critère de
pondération a trouvée pour ne pas se
faire uniquement un travail mécanique à
partir de la population parce que
l'objectif c'est quand même bien de
créer des communautés
de destin qui se prennent en main et de
favoriser l'adhésion de la population
donc faisons attention à à pondérer pour
arriver à une représentation équilibrée
des populations et la deuxième chose
c'est le chef-lieu a effectivement
aujourd'hui je me dis on est en train de
construire la france de demain et on
organisera autour de la notion de chef
lieu qui me semblait la notion d'hier au
moment où on parle de travail en réseau
on parle de chef-lieu et la question de
la capitale est une question qui va
vraiment être très sensible et très
compliqué donc pourquoi fixer le lieu du
chef-lieu par décret bon qu'on fixe le
lieu de sièges de l'assemblée mais le
siège de l'assemblée régionale c'est pas
forcément le chef-lieu mais faisons
attention à ne pas figer les choses ne
pas figer les choses en décrétant le
chef-lieu de cette façon là parce que
nous avons à construire
l'organisation de demain et elle peut
être multi centres multipolaire cette
organisation 1 voilà ce que je voulais
dire mais en tout cas je vous souhaite
d'excellentes travaux sur une réforme
qui se pense et une réforme si nous la
menons à bien devrait marquer la france
et nous ouvrir véritablement sur le
monde de demain donc merci davance la
sagesse que vous allez forcément amené à
ces travaux au milieu des passions que
nous sur les territoires connaissons
merci madame marie-guite dufay vous avez
vraiment la sensibilité pour parler aux
sénatrices et sénateurs nous voyons cela
alors eu monsieur
jacques auxiette président de la région
pays de la loire
très attendu merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les oui je pense qu'il ya
eu un petit enfin bon c'est par ordre
alphabétique ses parades et je vous prie
de m'excuser j'ai suivi mon papier le si
vous voulez je peux tout à fait si
monsieur jacques auxiette en est
d'accord de manière à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas d'interprétation des faces on
pourrait donner la parole de recherche à
monsieur philippe richert président de
la belle région alsace allez merci
jacques philippe richert tu je sens bien
je sens bien qu'il y avait là une
volonté d'exclure non pas dans tout le
seul membre de l'opposition des régions
mais justement je je je sens bien qu'il
avait une volonté alors jeux de suite
corrigé le tir tu vois bien alors je les
remercie vous n'avez pas encore sûr été
supprimés les régions qui ne sont pas de
la majorité nationale cessé de mojo je
reviens le hic c'est dommage comme tu
dis je reviens sur sur deux points j'ai
bien écouté ce qu'a dit le président de
l'assemblée des régions de france et est
le président de la région ile de france
ils ont beaucoup insisté je voudrais
faire la même chose en disant que en
fait la question de la taille n'est pas
la vraie question
et c'est je ne fais que reprendre ce
qu'ils ont dit un jeu je ne permettrai
pas moi en tant qu'opposition de le
formuler mais comme ils l'ont dit
j'insiste la première chose qui compte
c'est les ressources les compétences et
les ressources qui correspondent aux
compétences et ils ont eu l'honnêteté
de dire combien en ce moment les régions
vont être ponctionnées je me souviens
quand j'avais des responsabilités
ailleurs quand j'étais ici pour défendre
l'idée qu'il allait y avoir une
stabilité des finances que l'état
reverse et combien j'avais été attaqué
là dessus je constate que quelques
années après quand on diminue
sérieusement on n'oublie pas que avant
on avait juste stabilisée que l'avenant
ça descend conscrits concrètement alors
une fois qu'on a dit ça je veux redire
que je suis profondément régionaliste
que je pense que la réforme de notre
pays va passer par la décentralisation
et que la décentralisation de 10
renforcement des régions
tout le monde le dit je veux le répéter
mais on ne peut pas commencer à parler
des coupes assure n'a pas lé reste à
dire que ça n'a pas de sens si on ne
parle pas du reste et le reste c'est
notamment les compétences et la
répartition des compétences pas
seulement celles qui viennent des
départements la première des compétences
c'est celle qui vient je redis alain
roussel a dit je sais c'est qu'ils
viennent de l'état en particulier dans
le domaine de l'emploi par exemple il
faut qu'on aboutisse à une clarification
là dessus c'est sinon ça ne rit pas
qu'en fait pas grand chose et c'est
parce que nous avions ce discours en
alsace
avant même aujourd'hui que nous avons
essayé de faire en sorte que nous
puissions en alsace et expérimenter ce
qu'on appelait le conseil d'alsace par
la fusion des conseillers généraux et
des comptes des conseils généraux et des
conseils régionaux vous rappelez un
référendum aux 58 % des gens qui ont
voté ont voté oui 58 % ont voté oui
alors si vous appelez ça l'échec c'est
quand même 58% de vie mais pourquoi
est-ce que ça a échoué c'est parce que
ça ne représentait pas 25% des inscrits
nous avions sollicité le sénat pour
supprimer cette clause et c'était un
amendement qui avait été déposée par
françois patriat
cosigné cosigné
cosigné par jean vincent placé est
déposée par quatre est déposée par
catherine tremblay cosigné par
andré reichardt et cet amendement était
finalement torpillé au niveau du sénat
c'est c'est dommage parce que nous
pourrions être en ce moment en train
d'expérimenter cette solution qui était
une solution pas idiote pour l'alsace
permettez moi de le redire c'est dommage
que le sénat à l'époque n'est pas suivi
je les regretter voilà j'ai pleuré amer
amèrement de devant cette
incompréhension de la haute assemblée
que me fait payer aujourd'hui jean
pierre sueur bon
et pourtant lui il était d'accord oui
moi j'étais d'accord quand on s'était
rencontrés mais oui le président bayle
aussi et beaucoup d'autres aussi
notamment font se passe rien parce qu'il
me l'a redit après même visiblement
lorsque ça a été examiné en commission
la commission du sénat a dit il serait
temps que l'alsace se souviennent qu
elle fait partie de la république n'est
ce pas andré c'est un peu dommage alors
maintenant qu'on est là devant cette
situation que n'a pas pu faire le
conseil d'alsace
passion peut trouver une solution pour
le verre quand même moi j'avoue que ce
soit pas plus mal parce que c'est une
solution intéressante si néanmoins on ne
peut pas et qu'on en revient à cette
solution qui est proposé ici l'idée
d'une réunion avec la lorraine est
quelque chose qui à priori ne nous fait
pas peur mais faut qu'on puisse savoir
quand même une clarté dans ce qui est
proposé et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que aujourd'hui
la façon dont les débats sont engagés
c'est que la clarté s'éloigne de plus en
plus haut lieu de venir à peut-être que
là la sagesse du sénat va nous apporter
cette lumière nécessaire sans doute en
sortant du sénat je suis persuadé que le
texte sera clairement défini nous
donnera les pis nous permettra de voir
parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
quand on est sur le terrain pour
l'appliquer on se pose beaucoup de
questions une réunion entre l'alsace et
la lorraine aurait beaucoup de sens un
peu plus de 4 millions d'habitants un
pib global de l'ordre de 100 milliards
d'euros 110 milliards d'euros
pour avoir des projets communs pour
porter un projet
mais d'abord il faut être capable de
porter ce projet ensemble faut définir
projet comporte et pour l'instant on
peut pas différent le projet on est
juste à dire est ce qu'on serait unie ou
pas c'est un peu dommage qu'on n'ait pas
pu construire un peu autour travailler
ensemble moi j'avoue qu'à titre
personnel
il y a des interrogations mais il ya
aussi beaucoup de soutiens possibles
donc nous aurions besoin vie nous
aurions besoin qu'on ait des
interrogations sur la question des
compétences sur la façon dont ça va se
passer
là nous sommes juste avec un texte qui
nous dit pour l'instant
comment va élire et comment va regrouper
les régions c'est un peu court ce qui
fait que pour l'instant nous aurions
besoin d'avoir des précisions pour
pouvoir clairement nous prononcer voilà
aujourd'hui où se situe le débat en
alsace
si philippe richert président de la
région alsace et qui a rappelé la
réalité des choses comme quoi quelques
fois le cours de l'histoire tient à un
amendement
mais je ne sais pas bon alors tu on en
reparlera donc je donne la parole à jean
marie beffara vice président de la
région centre
non non non je suis l'ordre que
géographique pour ne pas créer de
malentendus
merci monsieur le président je serais je
serais très très bref d'abord pour
excuser françois bonneau qui préside en
ce moment même une session
extraordinaire de notre conseil régional
et du ceser sur le sujet qui nous
rassemble lui aussi aujourd'hui donc il
m'a demandé de le représenter et puis je
partage beaucoup de ce qui a été dit sur
les questions de compétence et de et de
financement et donc comme la région
centre est est au coeur d'une
proposition qui fait débat très
largement sur la carte qui est proposé
je concentrerai mon propos sur ce sujet
là et seulement sur celui ci
je crois dans une période où on aborde
beaucoup la question
avec interrogation de l'identité des
régions des futures régions notamment
l'exemple de la région centre est assez
édifiant et j'ai envie de dire rassurant
nous sommes une région qui a été composé
de façon assez hétéroclite qui va des
franges souffrent des franges
francilienne au nord jusque au berry
dans le sud en passant par le val de
loire orléans blois tours et je pense
que nous avons su en une trentaine
d'années créer une véritable identité
régionale en tout cas un sentiment
d'appartenance à un destin commun pour
les habitants de cette région et donc je
crois que il faut aussi affirmé qu' à
travers des politiques à travers
des élections direction de la jeunesse
de l'économie et des territoires on peut
créer des identités on peut créer de
l'appartenance quelles que soient les
conditions dans lesquelles les régions
sont sont constitués au départ et moi si
je dis ça c'est que j'ai lu ce matin
comme peut-être ainsi nombre d'entre
vous un journal pour ne pas le citer le
figaro qui parlait de deux d'objets
régional non identifiés en parlant de la
région sens je crois que nous ne sommes
pas nous serons jamais un objet régional
identifiés nous sommes une région à part
entière qui aujourd'hui
représente le 6ème
la sixième région industrielle la
première région céréalière et donc je
crois qu'il faut aussi et je tiens ici à
revendiquer l'identité et la fierté de
la région centre
ce qui a constitué un an cité c'est
aussi six et c'est le politique mais
c'est aussi
le val de loire aujourd'hui classé
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco par
l'unesco et à ce titre là c'est au tour
de la loire que notre avenir doit se
structurer que nous que nous voulons
structurer notre avenir et dont vous
l'avez bien compris c'est plutôt vers
les pays de la loire que notre notre
coeur et notre volonté de construire se
tourne nous avons aujourd'hui avec les
pays de la loire engagé de nombreuses
politiques et nombreuses coopérations je
pense notamment au tourisme vous savez
que la loire à vélo qui aujourd'hui fait
de de la région sont la première
destination mondiale le tourisme à vélo
accueille chaque année un million de
visiteurs sur les 6 millions de
touristes cas que la région centre c'est
aussi la recherche à travers le
cancéropôle grand ouest s'est aussi les
pôles de continuité c'est aussi un pnr
un des rares pnr inter-régionaux loire
anjou touraine et puis c mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les vins de
loire qui ne démérite pas sur la scène
nationale de la viticulture donc
cette volonté que nous avons
elle représente nous semble-t-il une
alternative crédible et dynamique à la
proposition du gouvernement d'une grande
région centre val de loire
je me suis exprimé avant jacques
auxiette peut-être aura-t-il des propos
un peu différents des miens j'ai cru
entendre qu'un certain nombre d'élus du
val de loire de en tout cas de la région
pays-de-loire inscrivaient leur avenir
davantage dans leurs façades maritimes
que sur leur
axe ligériens je ne sais pas si les
choses peuvent évoluer en tout cas je
souhaite qu'elles qu'elles évoluent dans
le sens que j'exprime aujourd'hui mais
je tiens à dire que quel que soit le
choix que ferait pays de la loire la
région centre veut inscrire son avenir
vers l'ouest parce que c'est vers
l'ouest que que nous sommes tournés
aujourd'hui est que si un autre schéma
devait voir le jour je crois que vous
allez dans l'est dans les heures qui
viennent aussi arrêté amende et un
certain nombre de choses au sénat je
tiens vraiment à vous faire passer ce
message là notre notre volonté c'est val
de loire pays de la loire d'abord
l'ouest en tout état de cause et est de
toute façon le mouvement parce que nous
ne croyons pas à l'immobilisme
ce n'est pas du tout ce que j'ai dit
poitou charentes étant pour moi à
l'ouest de la région centre si vous si
vous êtes capable de décoder à travers à
travers mes propos vous verrez que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas une position de
rejet vis-à-vis d'une ouverture à
l'ouest de la région centre parce que
c'est là que sont à venir devra se
construire bon merci jean marie défarat
vice président de la région centre qui a
donné l'occasion à monsieur le premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin
de signaler son arrivée
je le remercie
mais oui très concentré alors justement
l'intérêt monsieur raffarin justement de
retrouver le tour géographique de la
table c'est que après le val de loire
nous nous rapprochons de l'estuaire et
monsieur e jacques auxiette déjà annoncé
va enfin nous apporter sa parole
monsieur le président des pays de la
loire en m'excusant d'avoir fait un faux
départ
mais issue pour rien je reviens pas sur
tout propos initiaux simplement pour
dire il ya deux lois la deuxième telle
qu'elle est annoncée a été exprimée par
les uns et les autres comme étant la
plus importante
ce que je confirme
mais la première qui nous rassemble ici
ce soir c'est dans l'urgence d'après ce
que j'ai cru savoir
puisque l'horizon de mardi est annoncé
comme étant un moment déterminant pour
vous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
alors simplement j'ai pas toujours été
président du conseil régional de la
région des pays de la loire mais je
siège dans cette noble assemblée depuis
1977 donc c'est la silver economy et
j'ai siégé avec olivier guichard et
françois fillon et comme mes collègues
l'ont indiqué tout à l'heure ça fait
donc pas tout à fait 40 ans mais
quarante ans que nos régions ont été
installés j'ai rencontré récemment le
préfet de région monsieur camou ce qui a
été un collaborateur d'olivier guichard
qui a installé le conseil régional de la
région des pays de la loire c'était le 5
janvier
1974 tout juste 40 ans et donc comme mes
collègues l'ont indiqué tout à l'heure
et c'est pour ça que je raconte un peu
cette histoire le sentiment
d'appartenance
d'appartenance à un territoire qui s'est
forgé au cours de ces quatre décennies
était une réalité pour tous les
territoires français tous les
territoires français et ceux ci s'est
manifestée dans des réunions que j'ai
organisé sur lequel je reviendrai
je voudrais dire que
j'ai réagi avec étonnement et le mot est
faible
à la déclaration du président de la
république du 14 janvier
annonçant la diminution par deux des
régions françaises
et depuis cette date ma démarche a été
avec l'ensemble des collègues du conseil
régional et du ceser mais aussi les
autres acteurs du territoire régional a
été d'essayer
d'essayer comme ceci a été évoqué par
les autres collègues tout à l'heure
d'essayer de rationaliser de
rationaliser une réflexion permettant au
parlement et en particulier au sénat de
proposer une carte des régions
françaises pertinente pour une plus
grande efficacité
je rappelle que l'objet exprimé à
l'occasion des différentes interventions
du premier ministre et du président de
la république c'est bien pour constituer
des régions françaises
plus capable plus pertinentes notamment
en matière de relève de développement
économique je crois qu'il faut rester
sur ses fondamentaux même si toutes les
autres acteurs et des compétences qui
ont été rappelés par les collègues tout
à l'heure sont bien évidemment
essentiel compte tenu des compétences
sur lequel je ne reviens pas mais je
crois aussi que cette démarche là ne
doit pas rester franco française elle
doit aussi nous permettent de regarder
ce qui se passe en europe et de
positionner les futurs région dans une
perspective de dynamique européenne et
de compétitions européennes mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
votre responsabilité est donc grande
elle s'inscrit dans l'histoire de nos
territoires des réalités d'aujourd'hui
mais surtout
surtout elle va déterminer
pour de longues années pour de longues
années les conditions dans lesquelles la
france et en particulier parce que j'ai
entendu un bruissement tout à l'heure
quand on a parlé de l'ouest de la france
les conditions dans lesquelles l'ouest
de la france va pouvoir se développer et
être partie prenante de la compétition
internationale et européenne j'ai pas le
temps je ne développe pas la réalité
régionale d'aujourd'hui telle qu'elle
est dans la région des pays de la loire
5e 3 millions 6 aujourd'hui 4 millions 5
dans quelques décennies s'est annoncée
par l'insee troisième région
industrielle de france avec les
diversités qui sont liés au territoire
c'est quand même une réalité qu'il est
bon de rappeler qu'elle fait depuis
depuis cette date et ses annonces du
président de la république et du
gouvernement
nous avons réuni à deux reprises le 13
mai et le 5 juin
désassembler très élargie
conseil régional conseil hier régionaux
césaire universités tous les acteurs qui
ont bien voulu être présent ça a été
diffusée sur internet et je vais vous
donner les conclusions parce que ce qui
vous intéresse c'est de savoir comment
avancer dans cette démarche la première
conclusion de ces débats qui se suivent
qui sont qui se suivent depuis puisque
on a installé un comité de suivi un
comité de suivi toutes tendances
politiques confondues
toutes tendances politiques confondues
et tout niveau de collectivités locales
également représentés de manière à ce
que le cadre politique dans lequel on
doit s'inscrire c'est bien de fixer un
cadre général dans lequel la république
et la démocratie doit pouvoir
fonctionner après chaque formation
politique exerce son talent et pour
manifester ces différences mais
l'objectif d'avoir ce cadre le plus
consensuel possible ou que les
convergences puissent être les plus
nombreux ça a été notre réalité et je
salue tous ceux qui ont participé
résultat pas de tellement démantèlement
de la région
si je dis cela c'est parce que si j'ai
réagi comme cela c'est parce que nous
avions le privilège d'être déposé dans
toutes les cartes qui ont été publiés
ça a été dur n'est pas les seuls on
n'est pas les seuls mais on était au hit
parade dans cette démarche là c'est sans
doute parce que il ya beaucoup d'autres
activités autour de ce territoire
donc premier constat qui résulte encore
une fois du sentiment d'appartenance
collective toutes tendances politiques
confondues acteurs tout acteurs
confondus deuxième élément analyse
rationnelle puisque à travers ces
réunions je les ai pas là mais il ya
plein de documents de cartes alain
rousset a évoqué tout à l'heure on
dispose quand même les uns et les autres
un certain nombre d'éléments qui
rationalise les échanges au sens large
qui existe entre les territoires même si
au delà de cette rationalité il ya bien
évidemment d'autres éléments qui peuvent
intervenir donc deuxième conclusion
quasiment unanime de tous les acteurs si
fusion il doit y avoir elle doit se
faire avec la région bretagne
c'est la position que je porte non pas
en tant qu'auxiliaire mais en tant que
représentant non seulement du conseil
régional mais de l'ensemble des acteurs
du territoire régional j'ai pas le temps
de développer tous ceux qui ont
participé qui se sont exprimés vous
aurez ça dans les dossiers si besoin
troisième élément
dans la poursuite de ces discussions
troisième élément c'est la réflexion un
peu du passé
est le passé c'est pour les uns et les
autres qui l'ont connu la stratégie de
la datar porté par mon prédécesseur
olivier guichard date arias ar
aménagement régional qui a constitué
trois régions ouest atlantique bretagne
pays de la loire poitou charentes et
donc j'ai souhaité que l'on ait une
analyse complémentaire permettant de
voir si les analyses de l'époque de la
datar et est toujours pertinente il ya
donc cette hypothèse là qui a été livrée
qui vient encore complexifier le
dispositif mais c'est l'honnêteté
intellectuelle et politique de pouvoir
exprimer ceci devant vous et donc je
termine pour dire à mon collègue voisins
que bien évidemment on a et tu l'a
rappelé avec la région santé avec la
loire un certain nombre de coopération
unesco interloire sur le plan économique
également ce sont des réalités je crois
qu'il faut rappeler que les coopération
inter-régionale insuffisante de mon
point de vue insuffisante de mon point
de vue ne suppose pas qui est forcément
fusion
administrative ou politique des
territoires et j'avais souhaité auprès
du premier ministre précédent que le
futur hypothétique contrat de plan
intègre dans ses stratégies une
incitation aux coopérations inter
régional pour rationaliser comme le
projet qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
le propose mais pour rationaliser dans
les fêtes sur un certain nombre de
thèmes je ne développe pas dit réalité
qui existe déjà sur un certain nombre de
points je le dis quand même pour la
région des pays de la loire et la
bretagne il ya création d'une université
fédérale 17 universités
ça compte un peu par rapport aux
stratégies de développement économique
et de recherche tous nos pôles de
compétitivité tous nos pôles de
compétitivité oui il ya aussi cette ce
projet là il ya aussi ce projet là mais
il y en a un autre d'actualité également
ses les liaisons ferroviaires avec le
mans rennes et u11 débat public qui
améliore cette liaison avec l'ensemble
de l'ouest de la france et donc les
pôles de compétitivité sont depuis peu
tous inter régionaux entre bretagne et
pays de la loire ces éléments-là compte
un peu par rapport à la dimension de la
stratégie pour conclure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
j'ai cru percevoir que l'ouest avait été
le lieu de certaines difficultés
je les connais vous aussi je respecte je
respecte
comme mes collègues et encourage les
manifestations culturelles
et les langues régionales lorsqu'elles
ont sur le territoire du sens
mais je ne pense pas que la république
la république
doivent s'organiser
autour des seuls identité je vous
remercie
si monsieur jacques auxiette président
de la région des pays de loire je
demande la tension ya une grande
attention mais je demande l'attention
car toutes les régions de france y
compris la dernière qui s'exprimera sont
chères à notre coeur donc je donne la
parole à monsieur gérard vandenbroeck
vice président de la région limousin
bien merci monsieur le priant de
rappeler que le limousin est également
de chair à votre coeur je vous prierais
d'abord mesdames et messieurs des
sénateurs et sénatrices sénatrices et
sénateurs nuit avoir excusé le présente
région jean paul denanot qui
actuellement est à l'étranger qui m'a
donc demandé de le représenter
aujourd'hui pour vous faire part d'un
certain nombre de considérations qui
sont les considérations de la plus
petite région de la france continentale
je reviendrai tout à l'heure vous allez
avoir examiné un projet de loi ce projet
louable dans il comporte des exposés des
motifs sur lesquels nous avons
finalement peu de choses différentes à
dire que ce qui est annoncé jusqu'à
présent wave on a analysé le besoin de
clarifier les compétences nous sommes
d'accord on a évoqué le coût de
l'exercice des responsabilités nous
sommes d'accord on a évoqué des
objectifs évidemment efficacité des
actions publiques équilibrées dit rien
nous sommes évidemment d'accord on a
moins évoqué les moyens soient qu'il
faudrait bien que soyons d'accord moment
ou un autre puisque les moyens seront au
coeur de notre activité au coeur de
notre action il a été évoqué par le
président de l'association
l'été est ressuscité mais j'ose dire
aujourd'hui j'en étais restée à quel
prix et si demain des moyens nouveaux
doivent de nos régions il faudra aussi
que les transferts de compétence s'étend
sur les finances fritz envers le
financement
accompagné transfert de compétences mais
ceci étant dit le chapitre 1 c'est celui
qui aujourd'hui évident que s'intéresse
le plus disposition relative à la
délimitation des régions pour nous la
délimitation des régions doit obéir à
une histoire à des réalités économiques
et surtout un projet à un projet comme
un projet commun pendant sur les
compétences et projets communs attestant
des ambitions alors je vous ai dit la
région limousin c'est la plus petite
région de la france continentale c'est
la moins peuplée
c'est peut-être pour cela d'ailleurs
qu'elle est une qu'elle a elle une
identité régionale très forte qu'elle
n'est pas un objet régional non
identifié si tant est qu'il en existe
ailleurs mais le projet qui nous est
proposé aujourd'hui ferait de cette plus
petites régions de france continentale
la plus grande demain ferait de cette
région la moins peuplée aujourd'hui la
quatrième ou cinquième région la plus
peuplée et ceci étant cette région
d'origine le limousin n'aurait plus
qu'une représentation qui serait divisé
par deux alors tout cela pour vous dire
que la carte qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui pour nous apparaît tout
simplement invraisemblable et je ne vais
pas dire inacceptable mais peu
acceptable la région qui nous est
proposé elle irait du nord 2 rue au sud
de souillac quand j'étais enfant on me
disait que la france était de dunkerque
ce président que je connais que je
connais bien par ailleurs de par mes
origines lointaines de dunkerque à
perpignan que je connais bien de par mes
origines familiales
1000km
1000 km de dunkerque à perpignan
aujourd'hui du nord de dreux au sud de
brive ce serait quasiment 500 km la
moitié du territoire national c'est
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui nous
paraît tout à fait tout à fait excessif
donc tout cela nous paraît peu
acceptable
l'économie ne le justifie pas n'y a pas
d'identité culturelle entre toutes ces
régions pas d'histoire commune pas
d'économies commune aussi en va de
l'élevage bovins limousins sur des
parcelles moyenne aux grands de grande
superficie de la bosse que sais-je
encore rien rien ni dans l'économie ni
dans l'histoire dira la culture ne
justifie ce rapprochement et nous permet
d'avoir et nous permettrait d'avoir ce
sur quoi je voudrais insister un projet
régional construit comme un pour les
années qui viennent et c'est bien cela
qui attendent nos populations nous ne
répondrons lyon donc pas à la tante de
nos populations ça ne veut pas dire que
parce nous sommes petits parce que nous
sommes petits nous ne voulons pas
coopérer nous coopérons évidemment et
nous coopérons d'autant plus que nous
sommes petits c'est vrai que le massif
central on souffre on le sait bien dans
le cadre d'un critique de massifs c'est
vrai que poitou-charentes historiquement
d'ailleurs moi j'ai fait mes études à
poitiers monsieur le premier ministre
lorsque j'étais il ya quelques semaines
encore étudiant
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce chef de milice
c'est vrai avec midi-pyrénées dans le
cas du cancéropole par exemple je ne
prendre que cet exemple là il ya une
coopération multiples ce ce
rassemblement des régions malmo fusion
est un mot qui nous arrange un peu mais
bon on va l'employé quand même ce
rapprochement ce rassemblement se
réfugiant des régions pour nous elle ne
peut aller que vers l'ouest alors
l'ouest à l'ouest quoi de nouveau en ce
cas à l'ouest beaucoup de tentations
elle ne peut aller que vers l'ouest
parce que l'histoire nous porte ainsi
parce que la géographie nous portent
ainsi parce que l'économie nous portent
ainsi et nous avons demandé évidemment
au delà de nos préoccupations des élus
aux socioprofessionnels de travailler
sur ce thème c'est en ce sens que le
ceser vient de nous rendre hier un pré
rapport qui va exactement dans le même
sens notre tropisme si j'ose dire normal
c'est d'aller vers poitou charentes
c'est d'aller vers l'aquitaine
éventuellement si poitou charentes veut
se tourner davantage vers l'aquitaine et
nous n'avons pas d'opposition majeure à
ce rapprochement la qui d'ailleurs était
la première proposition qui nous a été
faite d'aller vers acquise à n'ya pas
poitou charentes mais il y avait déjà
aquitaine donc c'est bien cela vers cela
que nous souhaitons aller j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure et vous l'avez dit
certain dans deux régions l'ont dit il
ne doit pas y avoir
d'agrégation mécanique dans la
représentativité des élus mais il ne
faut pas non plus qu'il est sous
représentation corps dans la proposition
que nous fait aujourd'hui et j'aimerais
connaître sur la manière dont le calcul
a été fait il y aurait en tout c'est
l'alcool une telle sous représentation
de la région limousin que vous ne vois
même pas comment nous pourrions répondre
sur notre propre territoire on vous l'a
dit monsieur le président je vois pas
comment vous quant aux sollicitations
auxquelles nous avons déjà aujourd'hui
bien du mal à répondre voilà mais
mesdames et messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices ce
que je voulais vous dire ce n'est pas
parce que nous sommes une petite région
que nous manquons d'ambition nous en
avons au contraire peut-être plus que
d'autres je ne sais pas non tu as au
moins autant que d'autres parce que
nécessité fait loi et que nous avons
besoin de nous bouger peut-être
davantage que les autres
si monsieur gérard van den broucke vice
président de la région limousin enfin
notre collègue françois patriat
président de la région bourgogne
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les présidents jacques olek je suis la
neige va être très bref parce que pour
nous le problème de la carte n'est pas
un problème
mais ce que je voudrais vous dire que
même s'il n'est pas un problème c'est
que le moment que nous vivons mois jean
vila gravité la responsabilité
parce que le problème n'est pas de
savoir si on veut aussi on peut le
problème savoir c'est que nous devons
avancer la france doit-elle
faire ces réformes comme d'autres pays
l'ont fait je pense que oui nos
collectivités sont telles qu lisible est
simple je pense que non sont-elles
efficaces pas toujours sont-elles
coûteuse sans doute et qu'à partir de là
le problème n'est pas de savoir si nous
défendons tel ou tel de nos féodalité
mais si nous défendons l'intérêt bien
compris des habitants la question que
nous posons n'est pas de savoir si nous
faisons bien ce que nous faisons nous le
faisons souvent dans la complexité j'en
veux pour je me tourne dans mon ami yves
rome moi je vis entre la scora né laisse
dante depuis trois ans une complexité
insoutenable autres celui qui ferait la
stratégie du haut débit celui qui
réalisera lé haut débit
tout cela n'a pas de sens du très haut
débit bien très bien avec une ambition
trop dinars je vis là tous les jours
quand même dans une difficulté dans une
complexité dans des doublons dans jeunes
aujourd'hui je ne dis pas qu'ils doivent
être les maîtres eux mais je dis que
c'est là réalité est que nous devons
merci rachel de me laisser parler de
nous voilà devant est arrivé tout à
l'heure j'ai entendu des murmures quand
philippe richert s'est exprimé moi ça me
gêne pas que vous ayez des murmures
parce que je pense que ce sujet là et
les trans politique et qui nous concerne
tous et que c'est pas le problème de la
droite ou de la gauche ici c'est le
problème du territoire et que moi je
voyais l'expérimentation en alsace comme
un phénomène que nous devions regarder
accompagné étudiée et évaluée par la
suite s'il avait été réalisée
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je pense que
nous aurions devant nous en grandeur
réelle déjà d'expérimentation qui
pourrait nous accompagner et je regrette
je regrette que cette expérimentation
n'est pas eu lieu j'ai tenté de
l'accompagner pour le faire je pensais
qu'elle était volonté avec qu'il était
salutaire ceux qui on porte la
responsabilité par ailleurs je n'ai pas
à porter de jugement mais pourquoi nous
en sommes là aujourd'hui c'est parce que
le fait que nous sommes collectivement
responsables c'est pas la faute de telle
ou telle gouvernement celui d'hier ou
d'aujourd'hui chers collègues c'est
parce que je me souviens qu'avec claude
belot j'ai passé ici huit mois huit mois
avec krattinger avec d'autres pour
discuter de la pertinence de chacun de
nos échelon
qu'allons-nous des idées au bout rien qu
il ne fallait rien touché alors s'il ne
faut rien toucher disons le tous
disons le tout ce faut rien toucher et
bien on ne touche pas c'est bien tout
fonctionne on a répondu à une trois
premières questions et on continue comme
ça mais si nous sommes tous convaincus
et notre concitoyenne attendent que nous
devons changer alors comment nous a
devancés et si on n'est pas bougé depuis
six ans
quelle qu'ait été la majorité c'est
parce que collectivement chacun a voulu
rester sur son pré carré chacun a voulu
rester sur son pré carré tous tous tout
le monde personne n'a proposé de
solution sinon des algues des
aggiornamento moi je les prix comme tel
à l'époque j'ai passé un peu comme
provocateur à la commission claude s'en
souvient quand je disais que sur telle
ou telle proposition de la commission
balladur
j'apportais mon accord ou apporter mon
soutien j'ai entendu aussi des murs
d'eau dans cette salle quand je quand je
les fais parce que au bout du compte
maintenant d'un le gouvernement ce
gouvernement a un mérite c'est celui de
dire maintenant je veux avancer et je
vais décider quelle est la méthode celle
que le décidons aujourd'hui alors est
elle bonne je reviens pas sur les
compétences ce que j'ai dit c'est que
sur le découpage pour ce qui nous
concerne nous n'avions que deux
alternatives
la première c'est pour la région
bourgogne et la bourgogne franche comté
l'effacement au la réunion
l'effacement nous sommes deux petites
régions à toutes les deux pas trois
millions d'euros de budget des médias de
même pas non 2 millions de budget pas
trois millions 32 milliards pardon
pardon je veux je parle des habitants
pas trois millions d'habitants deux
budgets inde 800 et 1 500 à côté qui
était quitté qui font pas un gros budget
mais dans le même temps deux petites
universités de petits aéroports de chu
terra d'oc quelle est la situation pour
ce qui nous concerne ou bien nous nous
réunissons pour être une région
existantes entre les deux mastodontes
que vous représentez mes chers collègues
entre l'île de france et que j'admire et
la région rhône alpes que j'apprécie par
ailleurs mais pouvions nous existons
milieu sinon avec la tentation de voir
l'yonne partir vers l'île de france la
saône-et-loire que qu'à lire à tout à
l'heure partir vers rhône alpes le jura
partida rhône-alpes et d'autres partir
vers l'alsace donc on avait le choix
entre l'effacement et la réunion c'est
pour ça que c'est plutôt simple pour
nous et que je me suis inscrit dans
cette démarche maintenant je conclus en
vous disant que même si vous avons
décidé je mesure aujourd'hui les
difficultés d'aboutir
arrivé à rapprocher nos exécutifs arrivé
à rapprocher nos budgets arrivé à
rapprocher nos services arrivé à décider
tout cela est une tâche qui va demander
un peu de temps et si moi j'avais qu'à
regret c'est que cette réforme elle se
fasse peut-être avec un tout petit peu
mal précipitations au delà des cartes
que nous pouvons faire c'est là pour que
nous puissions effectivement la réaliser
et la réussir parce que l'objectif c'est
bien de la réussir est pas par savoir
nos états d'âme qui n'aurait aucune
importance face à l'enjeu que représente
l'économie elle devenir de notre pays
mes chers collègues merci françois
patriat président de la région bourgogne
je pense
et monsieur le président de la rs jours
merci les dix
présidents présidente vice président de
région qui se sont exprimés nous offre
un panorama très précieux pour nous je
les en remercie tous moi j'ai remarqué
que 1 il a été beaucoup question de la
force des régions il nous a été dit que
la force des régions n'est pas pro
forcément proportionnelle au nombre de
kilomètres carrés
il nous a été dit l'importance des
compétences il nous a été dit
l'importance des ressources et il nous a
été par les deux périmètres certes mais
aussi de gouvernance et de démocratie
rapport à la population
je pense je vous remercie vraiment
monsieur le ministre l'intérieur à
accepter venant sommes reconnaissants de
devenir qu'à 16h30 april ou aller dans
le département de mayotte biens dont il
nous reste un peu de temps
c'était important d'abord de vous
écouter je donne la parole à ceux qui
vont l'a demandé mais il me paraît très
réaliste et raisonnable qu'il n'y ait
que quelques interventions si possible
courte et tonique mais vu les doigts qui
se lève je n'en doute pas mais je donne
d'abord la parole à michel delebarre à
porter
ce président je n'avais pas levé la main
n'étant pas
tenant de telle ou telle région
mais je voudrais simplement rappeler que
il y as derrière ce projet de loi une
intention qui est de réduire le nombre
des régions vraisemblablement de le
diviser par deux de ne pas l'accroître
de ne pas couper dans les régions mais
au contraire d'essayer de rapprocher des
régions qu'ils soient des ensembles et
par ailleurs il n'y a pas non plus
volonté de voir un découpage par
département
s'installer dans le débat et modifier
énormément
les limites je n'ai pas trop entendu
d'ailleurs
ce risque dans les interventions des
différents présidents de
région mais ça peut-être venir mais
jeudi pour le moment je n'ai pas trop
entendu ce risque je crois pour la
réflexion du sénat que si nous voulons
pouvoir avancer à l'occasion de l'examen
de ce projet de loi
il ne faut pas choisir
le terrain d'avoir une multitude de
modifications
à apporter au découpage qui a été
présentée je crois que dans ces
conditions on aura vite fait le tour la
séance plénière sera
intéressante sur le terrain du parcours
géographique
voire de l'agrément de la visite
régionale mais je pense que l'efficacité
de l'examen par le sénat ne sera pas
terrible à l'arrivée de cette
confrontation
j'ai bien entendu aussi que les
compétences avaient leur importance
dans les choix qui peuvent être faits
mais sincèrement sur les compétences les
uns et les autres une petite idée de ce
que seront les évolutions des
compétences pour les régions et donc je
pense qu'au niveau de la réflexion cela
n'handicape pas la discussion sur
limites territoriales
voilà où nous en sommes monsieur le
président je ne suis pas même à l'issue
de ce demi tour de table des régions je
ne suis pas en état de dire voilà le
découpage
extraordinairement performance qui
succède à la proposition qui a été faite
donc je pense qu'il y encore nécessité
de réfléchir ensemble pour essayer
d'approcher une solution
si monsieur delebarre gers en syrie
demande de parole monsieur mazuir
monsieur sido monsieur husson monsieur
rome monsieur delattre monsieur
grosdidier madame bonne foi monsieur van
beirendonck est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres
oui attends je te vois pas monsieur
bertrand ça fait neuf demandes je
propose qu'on arrête là et que je
demande si vous pouvez tenir entre une
minute et deux minutes de manière à être
percutant vous êtes tous d'accord est
tous capables dont monsieur va suivre va
le premier se livre à cet exercice
je vais très court j'ai entendu beaucoup
de comparaisons avec nos pays voisins et
notamment on a parlé de l'angleterre et
de l'allemagne où la pauvreté se
développe allègrement en allemagne il y
à 16 % de pauvres alors que nous nous
sommes selon les critères bien connu 60
% du salaire médian alors que nous nous
sommes en dessous de 13 alors les
comparaisons de ce type je crois qu'il
faut s'en méfier même si ça concerne les
régions l'économie je veux dire que je
suis très dubitatif sur ce genre de
relation alors quel est l'objectif parce
que c'est ça en fait j'ai bien entendu
françois qui avait l'air de dire que si
dans notre france on avait ces
difficultés on allait en partie les
résoudre en réduisant le nombre de
régions en attribuant des compétences en
les spécifiant moi j'ai posé la question
à martin malvy et alain lambert qui sont
venus jacqueline gourault et là nous
expliquer les études enfin les auditions
qu'ils avaient
fait et ils n'ont pas répondu aux
économies que aux questions purement
économies qu'on pouvait faire par
rapport en région répartissant en
attribuant des compétences aux régions
et c'est aujourd'hui à la difficulté moi
on me pose des questions je suis
incapable de dire aujourd'hui quelles
économies on va faire en passant les
collèges s'agissait par exemple ou
là-haut région je sais que ça va coûter
22 me en plus à la région là j'ai fait
une petite étude avec les djs des
départements mais s'agissant des
transferts des routes j'ai pas d
explication j'ai pas d'explication
notamment s'agissant des transports
scolaires ils sont gratuits dans le
département de l'ain le seul département
quelle économie je vais faire est ce que
les autres vont être alignés elle voilà
donc aujourd'hui on n'a aucune réponse
ça et je pense que c'est quand même
l'essentiel si on veut
répondre à cet objectif qui nous est
proposé et à ses compétences alors après
reste bien évidemment l'éloignement bon
ça c'est je crois rené souchon qui a
bien expliqué les choses aujourd'hui
dans ma région rhône-alpes mois les
conseillers régionaux sont invisibles
demain il y en aura sept de moins pour
quatre départements de plus aux maisons
que voilà ce que je voulais dire non à
gien des réponses à apporter à rachel
mazuir a très bien passer son message
monsieur sido bruno sido il allait très
vite me ce prêt serait bien j'ai entendu
monsieur patriat dire qu'
aucun gouvernement n'avait bougé dois-je
dû rappeler que le gouvernement
précédent afin de la majorité précédente
avait créé le conseiller territorial que
vous êtes empressé de supprimer c'était
un mouvement qu'on peut ne pas apprécier
mais on n'avait bougé quand même
première chaud deuxième chose j'ai
entendu monsieur huchon dire mais à vrai
dire
problème des compétences une fois
absolument les routes mais est ce que
vous savez de quoi vous parlez monsieur
huchon je vous respecte infiniment mais
quand comme
c'est que je ne fais pas du tout de quoi
je parle de dialoguer je m'explique
c'est que comme vous êtes chargé des
transports mais vous avez la sncf et rff
tandis que c'est en régie que les
départements font leur route falloir
elle est transférée donc vous c'est
compliqué ce sont des ennuis il faut
alors aller sur le terrain
et puisque monsieur le président vous
nous avez demandé d'être percutant moi
j'aime bien écouter monsieur rousset qui
nous a dit je suis d'accord avec lui
d'ailleurs mais c'est pas la taille des
régions ni leur forme qui compte c'est
leur puissance c'est vrai mais si on
pousse c'est vrai mais si on pousse le
raisonnement un peu loin monsieur
rousset il suffit de donner toute la
puissance aux départements ils plus
besoin de régions
pieux ainsi dos donc vous avez fait
passer votre message incontestablement
monsieur huchon
ou d'émotion
il est pas là monsieur sont
tus on est en partie il n'a pas la
parole monsieur rome la reçoit bien et
il sera bref comme de coutume comme à
l'habitude en tout cas je voudrais dire
simplement on connecte patriat que la
légitimité il ne la possèdent pas et
puis ici je ne pense que personne ne
défend son propre sort mais plutôt à
l'intelligence de défendre le territoire
sur lequel il agit en tout cas c'est mon
cas et je suis apte à disposition pour
expliquer ce que ne comprend pas qui
préparera demain l'avenir parce que
c'est le vrai sujet et il faudra prendre
garde quel que soit le sort qui sera
réservé à cette réforme que les
syndicats mixtes ouverts soit préservée
pour que l'ambition française d'être
couverte à très haut débit puissent être
réalisés en tout cas pas une seule
collectivité ne pourra la réaliser tout
seul il faut des financements européens
il faut des financements nationaux ou
des financements régionaux il faut des
financements départementaux et il faut
des financements de
l'échelon communal ou intercommunal
alors pour le reste moi je voudrais
quand même dire que cette réforme faite
dans la précipitation
et j'ai bien vu que même à l'échelon des
régions des doutes subsistent et est au
premier rang de leurs présidents d'abord
effectivement il eût fallu commencer non
pas par les compétences enchères
président de la lrf mais peut-être par
la fiscalité parce que vous l'avez vous
même souligné vous allez très rapidement
connaître ce que les départements ont
connu dans le cadre des transferts
précédent
précédentes lois de décentralisation si
certaines collectivités ont des
difficultés c'est essentiellement dû à
la non compensation des compétences que
l'état a transféré au titre notamment
des personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées et du fameux rmi rsa bref et
moi je voudrais très rapidement attiré
l'attention sur une région particulière
j'ai bien entendu les difficultés de
l'ouest je peux vous dire qu'elles ne
sont rien à côté des difficultés du
mariage par exclusion de la picardie
avec champagne ardenne car oui mais on
parle moins que cela mais
malheureusement la réalité tout aussi
difficile mon département celui de
l'oise auquel je suis particulièrement
attaché qui justifie parfois mes colères
ou les emportements il faudra à près de
cinq heures aujourd'hui pour aller de
beauvais reims en passant par paris si
vous appelez cela en progrès moi
j'appelle ça une régression et je
considère que la picardie et
champagne-ardenne ont été sacrifiés sur
l'autel ou sur la peur de certains
risques que les dernières élections
européennes ont fait poindre au monsieur
robe je pense qu on dans le message est
clair non non non le message n'est pas
terminée moi j'aime pour moi je demande
et je plaiderai tout au long de l'examen
de ces textes pour que la picardie
puisse être prioritairement raccrocher
ce qui tombait sous le sens et qui a été
publiée par tout le nord pas de calais à
défaut à défaut de cela la région haute
normandie pourrait être également en
deuxième choix haute et basse normandie
à défaut je demanderai le détachement du
département de l'oise
comme certains de mes collègues picard
opéreront pour aller soit vers un
amandinois puisque la pointe et de ma
population bien travaillé tous les jours
à paris voilà bien monsieur europe
c'était complet et je redis que tous les
sénateurs sans exception premièrement
partagent un morceau d'intelligence on
est d'accord là morceau agepa dean
totalité et deuxièmement sont attachés
alors région leur territoire et leur
commune on est d'accord bon ce qui
permet de donner la parole à monsieur
delattre
de la région ile de france
mais ces régions de france il ya un
noyau riches il ya aussi des pauvres je
représente plutôt les pauvres alors je
souhaiterais dire au président huchon
que sa proposition
mérite d'être regardé de très près pour
la raison suivante nous avons
actuellement en chantier une métropole
avec les trois départements les plus
proches de paris ce qui va nous faire un
an 102,6 millions et demi d'habitants
franchement
consistant et riche
donc la grande couronne naturellement l
as quand même soyons pas naïfs d'en
pâtir
deuxième raison c'est complètement
stupide d'avoir une autorité qui décide
des transports et d'une autre qui va
décider notamment la métropole du
logement alors le système que propose je
découvre à vrai dire me paraît
intelligent parce qu'en réalité c'est
quand même un pas vers le fameux
conseiller territorial sont clairs à ce
sujet et ça nous permettrait de
continuer de travailler sur un gros
dossier une façon quand même un peu plus
harmonieuse
parce qu'autrement on va recréer
vraiment une différence trop forte entre
la grande couronne et le noyau dur de la
région parisienne alors l'idée d'avoir
une espèce de commissions permanentes
qui permet de discuter des problèmes des
départements permettrait peut-être
d'avoir un outil quand même un peu plus
performant eu égard aux problèmes
économiques et je serai de rééquilibrage
de la région parisienne âgée en moyenne
a besoin elles aussi d'être équilibrés
enfin en dehors de la région parisienne
je pense que sur le noyau dur des
régions sur les développements
économiques
il faut aussi s'intéresser puisqu'on en
train de travailler sur une espèce de
neutralité de décisions qui viennent de
l'état de bercy par exemple on vient de
voter ya deux ans le la non
déductibilité fiscale des intérêts des
emprunts faits par les entreprises
qui rapporte 4 milliards à l'état et
vous me dites monsieur présidents des
régions que vous avez fait un effort
très important ce que vous avez fait
investi 400 millions sur le secteur des
pme et des pmi bah là aussi il faut
qu'on réfléchisse un espèce de
coordination parce que le travail qui
pourrait être fait sur le terrain voir
des fois être dénaturée par des
décisions alors comment on peut imaginer
dispositif mais à mon avis il faut
l'imaginer monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
merci monsieur delattre alors monsieur
grosdidier va faire un effort de
concision il est coutumier de la
concision monsieur françois grosdidier
temps ça me sera facile mais bon si ça
sera plus dur mais vous allez y arriver
bien non mais je devrai d'abord dire
quelle occasion manquée
parce qu on est exactement dans le même
dans la même situation que sur les
problèmes de fiscalité de compétitivité
le gouvernement à commencer par démolir
ce qui avait été fait en ayant la
nécessité et maintenant on y revient
mais mais mais de moins bonnes façons je
suis heureux d'entendre les présidents
de région nous expliquer aujourd'hui que
al'inverse du gouvernement que le
problème ce n'est pas le périmètre mais
que le problème c'est les compétences de
je suis heureux d lisant ton de défendre
la spécialisation alors qu' on a rétabli
la clau 2 et de compétence générale je
suis mosellan voisin de la sarre l'inde
de moins d'un million d'habitants c'est
à dire moins que le département de la
moselle quand je vois ce qu'ils
consentent comme compétence et comme
budget ceux du département de la région
et toute une partie de l'état central et
c'est pourtant pas le land le plus riche
d'allemagne est encore moins le plus
peuplé ils ont une force de frappe
absolument considérable qu'on leur envie
et une plus grande efficacité
public donc c'est le modèle vers lequel
il fallait tendre et je veux former les
allées regret que plutôt que de démolir
le conseiller territorial si c'était le
mode de scrutin qui nous divise et
fallait que vous en adopter un autre
aurait peut-être changé fallait
peut-être un scrutin mixte mais il
fallait il valait stabilise et je dirais
les institutions et m à côté la question
du mode de scrutin qui est quand même le
texte qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
depuis ce matin puisque à des d'adopter
en conseil des ministres mais il valait
bien mieux limiter le combat droite
gauche au mode de scrutin et non pas sur
le périmètre des collectivités on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation
absolument aberrante
dire ouh ouh jeu je ne veux pas parler
de l'alsace lorraine qui me concerne en
rappelant quand même que ça jamais été
une communauté de destin choisi par des
habitants mais un sort subi par le
diktat du 2e rei victorieux et que c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que
laurens je suis je regarde la géographie
comme tout le monde et joie bien qu
entre nantes et rennes
outre l'histoire il ya même pas 30 40 km
de rupture entre les deuxièmes urbaine
et que ça fait à peine plus qu entre
metz et nancy et moins qu entre metz et
strasbourg donc et et qu'on a le
sentiment qu'on en une après-midi à des
heures différentes
changer la carte et qu'on n'a jamais
fait de façon aussi capricieuse dessiner
une carte de france qui les pressions de
région vont elles nous l'ont rappelé
vont nous engager pour des décennies
alors monsieur le rapporteur je suis
désolé mais ça mérite quand même un
examen en profondeur ça mérite des
amendements et peut-être que le serna
fournissent la réflexion que le
gouvernement en une après-midi en
quelques coups de gueule entendu n'a pas
réglé et ça mérite un véritable débat
parlementaire parce que ça nous engage
pour longtemps mais quelle occasion
manquée on pourra peut-être se dire au
sénat doivent d'avoir cassé une réforme
ne pas la boire éventuellement modifier
conforter changer aller plus loin dans
la spécialisation 1 que quand on est
certains ont défendu même à droite j'ai
j'arrête là où l on soit la double
compétence dans le sport ou la culture
ou tourisme veulent aller plus loin dans
la spécialisation mais c'est dans cette
voie là je crois que c'est celle là que
devrait emprunter le sénat pour faire un
travail sérieux plutôt que d'adopter
comme il est le travail tout de même
bâclé qui nous a été présenté en conseil
des ministres ce matin j'arrête là
excusez moi pour être percutant non
merci monsieur grosdidier c'était
parfait vous ai dit qu'il fallait un
débat et dire j'observe que depuis tout
à l'heure nous ne faisons rien d'autre
que de débattre donc nous répondons à
votre sollicitation et nous avons raison
de le faire madame bonne foi merci
monsieur le président nicole bonnefoy
sénatrice de la charente par ailleurs
conseillère générale d'un petit canton
rural avec 26 communes et ancienne
conseillère régionale de poitou
charentes moi je voudrais bien sûr
souligné que je ne suis pas du tout
opposé au redécoupage des régions dès
lors qu'il faut des régions est plus
forte même si comme nombre de mes
collègues je partage l'idée que ce n'est
pas tant le problème des périmètres mais
d'abord le problème des compétences et
des moyens que l'on accorde ceci dit il
est important bien évidemment que ce
redécoupage puisqu'il doit y avoir
redécoupage il se fasse sur des mains
principe de cohérence et qui
correspondent à la tente des administrés
concernant la région qui aujourd'hui
proposée par le gouvernement et qui
rassemblerait le centre le limousin et
le poitou charentes on en a déjà évoqué
ici plusieurs fois ce périmètre il nous
paraît parfaitement incohérent en effet
il est indispensable pour rapprocher des
régions que c'est cesser rapprochement
se fasse entre des régions qui
entretiennent des liens forts qui ont
l'habitude de travailler ensemble qui
ont des réseaux de transport qui les
rapproche qui partagent un souk
historique économique géographique
touristique culturelle en commun
rajoutez à queue en ce qui nous concerne
la région poitou charentes nous sommes
aujourd'hui traversée par la ligne à
grande vitesse atlantique qui va donc
nous rapprocher les charentes de
bordeaux qui va nous mettre à 30 minutes
à un trajet de bordeaux donc pour nous
il est parfaitement impensable de couper
ses liens naturels pour les tournées
vers une région difforme
qu'on qualifie dorny ça a été dit avec
aucune par ailleurs aucune métropole
identifier je dirai comment départements
la charente et avec elle la région
poitou charentes convergent parfaitement
vers l'aquitaine et c'est ce qu'ont
exprimé nombre d'élus qui se sont
mobilisés dans mon département en
prenant des délibérations c'est aussi
les départements de la région poitou
charentes donc charente maritime la
vienne et une partie des communes des
deux sèvres qui se sont exprimés pour ce
rapprochement comme les nombreux acteurs
économiques associatifs judiciaire et un
nombre important de la population puisse
comme pour un sondage a eu lieu
récemment avec 80% la population
charentaise qui considérait la nécessité
du rapprochement vers l'aquitaine vous
disiez tout à l'heure à juste titre que
ces nouveaux nouvelles régions devaient
trouver l'adhésion de la population qui
on devait construire un sentiment
d'appartenance à un territoire la région
telle qu'elle nous est proposé
aujourd'hui ne
répondent pas à cette adhésion de la
population et nous ne sentons pas ce
sentiment d'appartenance donc assez à
cette région est proposé dans ma
question main est simple elle se tourne
vers le président de l'aef qui est par
ailleurs président de la région
aquitaine est donc lui demander ce qui
est pense d'une région qui serait une
région poitou charentes aquitaine et si
josip et limousin puisque le limousin
aussi aimerait se rapprocher du de
l'aquitaine et madame bonne foi monsieur
van dieren donc
écouter la meilleure manière d'être
courtois
devant cette assemblée s'est d'abord de
saluer monsieur le ministre
ensuite de dire à mes collègues tous
bords confondus
que si le sénat a pu être
aussi à porter de débats et d'idées
dans le premier texte que nous avons
adoptée avec l'assemblée nationale et à
peu c'est parce que précisément
nous avons dépassé les clivages
partisans
et voilà les qui les clivages partisans
renouant ainsi avec ce que dit l'article
24 de la constitution assure la
représentation par le sénat
des collectivités territoriales souvenez
vous la peur rétrospective du haut
conseil des territoires
donc on est maintenant dans un
calendrier serré mais que nous restons
attendu si le gouvernement ne s'était
pas risqué à et la carte
que n'aurait-on attendu
alors on est dans un calendrier pas
possible
je reconnais
et on a vraiment besoin de la
participation de tous pour retrouver
l'esprit du premier tech c'est à dire
une coproduction de ceux qui veulent
faire avancer la démocratie
locale
qui laisse tomber les clivages partisans
à toi c'était lé conseiller territorial
moi c'était
aussi départ très honnêtement moi ce que
je cherche c'est qu'une occasion un il
faut décider des lois et moi on est des
purs produits de pierre mauroy il faut
décider voilà comment commence et le
rapport balladur ici même rapport
raffarin crac ag a à l'unanimité
il ya donc une doctrine au sénat sur ces
questions avec une certaine permanence
eh bien il faut la mettre en oeuvre en
l'actualisant à l'époque voilà seul et
l'état d'esprit dans laquelle on se
situe
merci heureux nepentes d'irène donc j'ai
encore deux intervenants je salue
monsieur le ministre bernard cazeneuve
qui a bien voulu accepter
d'abord de décaler qui peut être
d'attendre encore quelques minutes je
l'en remercie dont j'ai deux inscrits et
puis franchement je crois qu'il est sage
d'arrêter après pour que nos présidents
puisse dire quelques mots en présence du
ministre en plus donc les deux inscrit
son monsieur jarlier monsieur fortassin
monsieur jarlier
et monsieur bertrand dont j'en ai 3 donc
je me suis géré lit et monsieur bertrand
après et dans l'ordre monsieur fortassin
après monsieur jarlier merci monsieur le
président je vais être très court je
pense comme de beaucoup beaucoup d'élus
qui se sont exprimés la question n'est
pas la taille de la région mais bien le
problème de la compétence des moyens et
du projet collectif dans les nouvelles
régions qui vont être dessinée nous
allons avoir deux grandes régions dans
lesquelles il y aura des zones urbaines
des zones rurales des zones pauvres des
zones riches et une question absolument
essentiel qu'il faudra évoquer qui a été
évoqué par plusieurs présidents de
région c'est la question de
l'aménagement du territoire et la
question de l'égalité des territoires
parce que c'est bien à cette échelle là
qu'on trouvera les solidarité nécessaire
pour faire de l'aménagement du
territoire opérationnels et efficaces et
donc il manque dans ce texte à mon sens
quelques points qui pourrait rappeler
cette nécessité pour ces nouvelles
régions d'un rôle de solidarité et
d'aménagement du territoire hall au delà
évidemment des schémas régionaux tout
partira bien des schémas régionaux
majeurs du territoire mais la question
c'est l' équilibre des territoires et
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup
d'inquiétude parce que justement les
secteurs qui sont ruraux moi je vois le
cantal qui est très loin de très loin de
lyon on est assez d'accord sur le
rapprochement rhône alpes auvergne eh
bien on se dit mais on va être loin on
aura on sera pas entendu leur appel donc
la politique d'aménagement du territoire
dans les régions sera absolument
essentiel est le premier signe sur le
ministre monsieur le président ce sera
que la représentation dans ces
territoires ne soit pas à la baisse
parce que si on avait sans doute petter
de conseillers territoriaux ce qui était
quand même un des problèmes on est
peut-être redescendu un petit peu trop
parce que du coup un département que le
département du cantal qui avait
seulement cinq conseillers régionaux en
aura plus que 3 donc je pense que c'est
un problème d'acceptabilité donc
aménagement du territoire et
représentation équitable
qui monsieur jarlier
monsieur alain bertrand
oui ça marche
merci
je je suis pas tellement d'accord avec
ceux qui disent il faut décider non il
faut décider il faut bien décidé je
dirais c'est l'intérêt du gouvernement
d'ailleurs que je soutiens et du
président de la république et de son
gouvernement
ensuite
c'est vrai que les remarques qui vient
de faire jarlier c'est la dernière de
ces flous c'est la bonne quid de l'hyper
ruralitic prix de ces territoires
fragiles dans ces grades assemblage
ensuite je me faire brièvement une
remarque au président de l'association
des régions à lui disant qu'il a dit que
la carte convenait à tous les présidents
notre jour un télévision c'est fou moi
si je me réfère à la région où je suis
la région donc à demander à rencontrer
monsieur le ministre casey's sur le
premier ministre pour dire qu'on n'était
pas d'accord sur le découpage de la même
façon je trouve pas que tirer argument
du pays basque espagnol qui est une
région autonome pour le coup le comparer
avec nos régions françaises soit une
bonne façon de faire entre nous ensuite
ce que je voulais dire au président
président du sénat rapporteur et au
ministre c'est que car on prend cette
carte avec un crayon gris d'havas micola
divise en deux on peut y lire au sud
mathématiquement quatre régions 25 et
honore 8,5 région alors d'accord c'est
les compétences on est tous d'accord
d'accord ce qui compte c'est d'avoir la
taille critique la bonne taille critique
pour une région pour faire de l'économie
de l'emploi et être efficace dans le
cadre la politique du président de la
république françois hollande et du
gouvernement mais on ne peut pas s'en
tenir à des contres mal taillée la carte
il faut la part faire absolument et je
crains que le sud une fois de plus nous
soyons malheureusement encore trop loin
de paris d'ailleurs d'une somme de plus
en plus loin un dernier mot pour dire
que la lozère 1 pour ne pas évoquer mon
cas avec osi régionales sous la
présidence de jean pierre bel est la
présence de jean pierre sueur on a fait
une proposition de loi rdse pour dire
que le minimum minimorum monsieur le
ministre pour un département a fait
qu'il se représentait à la région
c'était 3 creuse et régionaux ce qui
permettait d'en reine de la majorité et
de l'opposition
si je regarde le cas du département qui
m'intéresse il va y avoir 150
conseillers régionaux dans la région
midi pyrénées languedoc roussillon et il
y aura un conseiller régional pour la
lozère c'est complètement inacceptable
au titre des principes républicains et
des principes de réalité ensuite je
crois que les présidents de région on
dit qu'il souhaitait quelques
modifications de cartographie certains
voulant se réunir davantage d'autres
préférant d'autres alliances et bien je
crois qu'il nous appartient de faire une
carte qui sont pas une carte pour
décider vite mais une carte pour décider
bien voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
monsieur le président est monsieur le
ministre merci alain bertrand enfin on
va finir avec la sagesse de monsieur
françois fortassin
président mesdames et messieurs je serai
très bref
premièrement je ferai une comparaison
avec la réforme de fer mitterrand elle
été comprise par l'ensemble nos
concitoyennes parce qu'elle était simple
il s'agissait de rapprocher le citoyen
utilisateur
de l'élu décideurs dans cette réforme je
cherche vainement une ligne directrice
ça c'est le premier élément le deuxième
point si on doit réformer pour le
plaisir de réformer
c'est un peu court il fallait d'abord
savoir qu'est ce qui marche mal dans
notre pays
soit que ce soit fait par le conseil
général que ce soit fait par le conseil
régional où que ce soit fait par les
communes ou les intercommunalités et
ensuite on établit une réforme là j'ai
le sentiment qu'on est dans une certaine
précipitation
cela dit moi je fais confiance à
l'intelligence des hommes pour s'adapter
et je ferai une comparaison
il ya quelque 40 ans tout ce qu'il y
avait en france deux démographes de
géographes de politologues de
spécialistes tous bords et de tous poils
ils nous disaient les campagnes
françaises
c'est fini vous pourrez éventuellement
freiner un déclin inexorable mais vous
allez vers une mort lente
c'est tout le contraire qui s'est
produit
alors j'ai le sentiment que peut-être on
trouvera quelques parades tant qu'il y
aura dans ce pays des élus mais
n'oublions pas quand même que notre pays
s'est forgée 6 il est si beau grâce à
une très grande nombre d'élus
même dans les petites communes encore
faudrait-il qu'ils puissent avoir le
sentiment de servir à quelque chose
désormais ti françois fortassin
avec la la grande indulgence de monsieur
le ministre bernard cazeneuve je vais
demander à nos présidents de région et
d'abord au président alain rousset s'ils
peuvent de manière peut-être un peu
cursive apporter quelques réflexions
oui les interventions si vous le
permettez je veux m'exprimer au nom des
des collègues à moins que
de deux ou trois points
encore une fois nous insistons auprès de
vous pas sur cette
base sur ce projet de loi
sur le fait que ce qui est fondamental
c'est la puissance
que nous sommes réservés pour ne pas
dire plus ça reste entre nous sur les
problèmes de taille parce que si l'on
veut s'occuper des entreprises des
transferts de technologie de
l'accompagnement des chômeurs ça suppose
une forme de proximité et qu' il ne faut
surtout pas que nous ayons une
désincarnation après le résultat des
européennes
une désincarnation des politiques menées
des élus menée à l'égard de nos
concitoyens
il y a une vraie crainte je pense
d'ailleurs que le miz intérieur le
gouvernement présidents de la république
ont bien pris ça en compte lorsque on
est passé en quelque sorte de 11 à 14 1
d'une certaine manière
il appartient au législateur que vous
n'êtes que nous sommes de faire le cas
échéant bouger la carte
j'ai pour ma part - regrets personnels
mais c'est vrai que c'est extrêmement
compliqué sur le plan constitutionnel
démocratique de deux vitesses de qu'on
n'ait pas pu avoir un découpage plus fin
il y a en fait quatre ou cinq
départements qui pose problème
je regarde ma collègue de charente et
charente-maritime
quoi sur l'aménagement du territoire je
voudrais rassurer les sénateurs qui est
les sénatrices qui sont ici les régions
prendront parfaitement en compte les
territoires ruraux et suburbains
pour lesquels une politique
contractuelle doit être mise en place à
l'échelle des pays il ne s'agit pas pour
nous de laisser tomber quelque
territoire que ce soit les régions les
régions prendront la responsabilité je
rappelle quand même que ce qui est
important pour un territoire c'est que
l'activité agricole l'activité
industrielle activités artisanales se
développe
plus que les ronds-points
ne 9e
khwaja de floris si j'ose m'exprimer
ainsi
sur
jeu juste une remarque à deux ou trois
reprises sur mais les comparaisons que
fait la rfa à l'égard des autres pays je
commande et un ne réinvente pas la roue
mais chers collègues il y à des
expériences européennes
soyons modestes aussi il y à des
expériences européennes qui fonctionne
bien en réussite scolaire mieux que nous
et de loin voir les rapport pisa en
santé en santé sauf que si les régions
les départements et les communes
n'avaient pas été là pour faire bouger
l'éducation nationale pour apprendre les
langues pour accompagner les élèves dans
la mobilité pour régler le problème du
logement des jeunes rien ne se serait
passé rien ne se serait passé
là dessus
pardon d'être un peu passionné mais
quand l'état nous a laissés dans les
années 80 les lycées c'était dans un
état déplorable aujourd'hui dans toutes
les dans tous les lycées professionnels
de france dans tous les lycées
professionnels de france quelle que soit
la sensibilité des exécutifs les élèves
travaillent avec le meilleur matériel et
la numérisation des lycées
professionnels et meilleur
donc là dessus je crois que il y a eu un
apport et chaque fois qui a une
compétence spécialisés cette compétence
a été parfaitement exercer chaque fois
que nous avons des compétences disperser
le temps de la décision publique et le
coup de la décision publique et 8 fois
plus élevés et y compris par rapport à
l'état et en saluant le ministre de
l'intérieur je lui dit précisément la
demande des régions de france qui est
qu'on règle le copain qui est plutôt que
le problème essentiel pour nous région
c'est que l'état
se départissent
nous transfère tout ces doublons
notamment dans le domaine économique
notamment dans le domaine de
l'innovation avec
les régions or il n'y a rien dans la
deuxième loi monsieur le ministre il n'y
a rien le deuxième point qui est
gravissime jeu l'évoquent devant le
ministre je vous évoqué tout à l'heure
en gros en innovation les régions de
france
m 400 millions d'euros les länder
allemands mettent 9 milliards d'euros il
ne faut pas s'étonner si nous n'arrivons
pas à redresser l'industrie française
si demain
sur le plan de la partie des compétences
départementales qui serait transférée à
la région à travers le développement
économique et excusez moi de parler du
deuxième texte qui nous semble plus
important que le premier
si les deux milliards que mettent les
départements ne sont pas transférés aux
régions c'est un drame pour les pme et
l'emploi
c'est un drame pour les pme et l'emploi
voilà je reviens je reviens d'un mois
mais à mes comparaisons essayons mes
chers collègues je je reprendrai les
mots de notre collègue vanderlinden va
partir avec lequel on a beaucoup
travaillé et je le remercie et régions
de france remercie les sénateurs et
sénatrices travail qui a été fait à
diverses reprises
parce que c'est une petite révolution
culturelle à un moment donné de se dire
le bon niveau du développement
économique le bon niveau du
décloisonnement de la recherche la
formation et l'entreprise c'est la
région
on pouvait se poser la question où
président de région comment le sénat
allait réagir un renforcement des
régions donc félicitations au maire ses
remerciements mes chers collègues mais
regardons l'avenir
essayons d'unir les forces politiques et
faisons en sorte et faisons en sorte
aussi que les meilleures expériences
européennes puissent être développés ici
en france on n'est pas attaché forcément
à du conservatisme
merci alain rousset je pense que les
différents présidents de région se
reconnaissent dans ce qui a été dit
laurent beauvais va ajouter un mot
simplement sur le premier tech
la référence au seuil minimal d'un
conseiller régional par département et
la problématique de la ruralité et
deuxième remarque que j'avais fait tout
à l'heure sur le chef lieu entre
guillemets ce terme je le trouve un peu
désuet et la préoccupation d'aménagement
du territoire en rapport avec les
métropoles et leurs compétences voilà
voilà pour cette audition d'alain
rousset et de nombreuses autres
présidents de régions de france qui ont
donc été auditionné par la commission
des lois du sénat dans le cadre de ces
travaux préparatoires à la réforme
territoriale une audition un type
exceptionnel puisque vous l'avez vu un
jean pierre bel le président du sénat
étaient également présents je vous
rappelle que la réforme territoriale
sera examiné au sénat à partir du 1er
juillet 2014 sur la première partie de
la réforme celle qui concerne la
nouvelle carte de france et les 14 super
région pouvait toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après midi
à 14 heures 45 pour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement présenté par
perrine tarneaud très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires